seconds
okay all right we are live episode 66
this is a first
tom zenner and gerard on the podcast
together today
we haven't done this together right you
and okay all right you can automatically
tell me i'm
wrong by looking over in this direction
because it's a little awkward sitting
over there instead of sitting here a
little different
okay so look we got a lot we got a lot
of things to cover here one thing we
have to cover is the following folks if
you're one of those that just got in
early i got a question for you gerard
yesterday told me how much he bench
presses
i said you got to be kidding me says no
pat that's how much i benched i said
come on he says
pat i bench press so i said chad kai why
don't you guys
go and see and gerard's like i'm up
they went to the gym and they bench
present i want to see if you can guess
do you actually know the answer i do not
know the answer what do you think he
bench pressed yesterday
at the gym if you were impressed i'm
going to say
like that's a lot are we talking one rep
one like a max out yeah
if you're if you're throwing the weight
around on a regular basis
look i think you look like you could do
that i'm gonna give you a 325 okay
sounds good i weighed in at 309 by the
way you're waiting at three or four you
know so you're down from three pounds
good that's great man there you go good
stuff okay yeah
so this florida thing is uh is good for
you i'm thinking about this
okay so if you're watching this i'm
curious what do you think you bench
pressed yesterday number two we got a
lot of other stories but
there's a disappointing story that came
up that i think we have to start off
with and i hope it doesn't break your
heart okay
i hope you guys can emotionally handle
this one here especially folks out there
that are
um struggling with a lot of uh
challenges that they're going through
stats came out yesterday okay
that a name that was named
in 1965 33 000 kids were named karen
last year only 3 25. heartbreaking
are you disappointed by them my
godmother can you please pull that up
my godmother's name karen variely
i swear karen variely i mean this is
news
go type in go actually uh go to go type
in
just go on google and tap in karen name
popularity
name popular look at the stats here man
it's it's uh you haven't seen it right
there just go down to come up
just type in popularity not the graph
just any article
any article kai you can go to any
article there you go look at this go to
uh tmz go for it name carrot popularity
plummets from
32 000 to 325.
uh number 668 31
uh 325 carrots versus 33
000. by the way go to the other website
i gave you go to the other website i
gave you
so i looked up our names okay i looked
up our names
go to it's crazy if you go to jennifer
i'll go all the way down on
popularity go all the way down on
popularity jennifer was number one for
an entire decade go all the way down
jennifer always tells me about this look
at this from 1970 baby if you're
watching this till
1981 jennifer was the number one
name in america what happened
i have no idea what that's like millions
right every year that's like
jennifer jennifer jennifer jennifer go
to gerard look what gerard looks like i
studied all year now
i've been investigating i can't wait for
my
way so unique do girard let's look up
gerard gold popularity if you go down
look at that look at that
if that was a stock that's not a good
stock but by the way all of our stocks
look like that
go down this is what it looks like
gerard's not even ranked
not in the last few years but gerard's
peak was
uh keep going down keep going down keep
going down okay you got to go up there
was a 179 you racked one keep going up
there was 179
ranking uh 177 at the time
when 54. my father 1958. look at that i
was born in 58. yeah jerome where you're
going
to do this it was 191. now type in
thomas
thomas here we go a very rare name yeah
you don't know
it's it's not i stand out in my family
it's the rarest name are you doubting
thomas
go down go look at the look at the stock
at the top by the way go back up there
will you come back to the trend look
from eighteen
okay is that roosevelt where everybody's
name and their kids uh
well that's teddy then it goes 1950 or
pekin
then go all the way down let's look at
the ranking look at this but you've been
in the top 50 for quite some time
top ten extremely competitive name for a
long time now go to patrick go to
patrick go to patrick let's check this
out
kai you may want to test yourself out as
well in america although it's probably
a higher ranking in different places
look at patrick we peaked
i wonder what happened in in the 70s and
60s we peaked
major drop off we got some work to do
right now it's ranked 205 gold lower
color the highest we got to was in the
30s
30 30 and then boom dropped off now is
this percentage based or is this just
right
so who which name was given the most
during that year
we're just not having kids anymore our
generation is not having kids well uh
that would be actually a great uh uh uh
segway into what china just announced i
don't know if you've heard about china
just announced i think that's a story we
got to go to page nine
china will allow moving forward folks
china
will allow couples to have three
children in a major policy shift
designed to reverse shrinking birth
rates
this is business insider story china
said on monday that married couples may
have up to three children major
policy shift from the existing limit of
two after recent data showed a dramatic
decline in births
in the world's most populous country
beijing scraped this decade old one
child policy in 2016 replacing it with
two child
limit that failed to trigger sustained
surgeon birds experts say the main
barrier to have children in china is the
high cost of raising kids in a poll
uh the weibo account of the official
state-run press sec
press agency asking are you ready for
the three-child policy
about 29 000 of the 31 000 responders
said they would never think of it
while the remainder would choose among
the options i've
uh i'm ready and very eager to do so
it's on my agenda
i'm hesitating and there's a lot to
consider the poll was later removed
fines of twenty thousand dollars were
given
imposed on people for having a third
child
as late of last year twenty thousand
four hundred forty dollars if you have a
third child yeah this is the thing about
this just shows the
the nerve of the chinese government i
mean it doesn't listen but doesn't it
inspire you say i just wanna move to
china
oh my god the chinese dream because you
don't have to think they'll just tell
you what to do at every every step of
the way
you know uh it is an issue you know
they're declining birth rate i mean if
the chinese government is this
interested in it they are worried about
it but you know
when when you research this story you
realize these young people don't want to
have kids it's way too damn expensive in
china
and they're serious about that and you
know what else they don't want to do
they don't want to work as many hours as
they used to
that 996 thing that was popular in china
with jack ma and everything
they don't feel like there's any payoff
to that anymore if you got in the
beginning of the tech industry and you
could really cash in on that they were
all in but
they they're they're pushing back on
that they're definitely pushing back on
the kids i think a lot of them don't
even want to have one
they don't have time to raise one child
so
it's nice to see you know the
non-compliance of the chinese people and
just tell them to shove it
well you know it's not it's not an issue
that that's endemic to china either i
mean that's an issue for the communists
in brooklyn and
los angeles as well it just goes to for
me to show how
little regard for humanity the baseline
of humanity
that communists really have they see
everything
as a spreadsheet they see everything as
a number uh
it scares me a little bit that china
wants to ramp up its population because
i think they're prepping for war and
they want to have they want to have some
more people ready
to uh to to storm the shores if you will
but um yeah the uh the the the concept
by the way of the one child
um we don't talk about in our country
enough and again we we talked about this
the last time i was on with
lebron james and john cena and all of
our repentant rich
who who carry water for for the ccp
every chance that they get
and this is what what they do this this
is what they're co-signing on
what they're co-signing on is social
engineering what they're called signing
on is cultural hegemony and
it it's it's an embarrassing thing for
us as a society to say
well i want to have a really popular
movie so i guess it's okay that this
woman had a second child and they put
the baby in a basket down the river
because they didn't want to find like i
mean it's insane well the cool
the cool thing is dr fauci is going to
help them out he said whatever you guys
need i'm behind you 100
we'll support this five kids i'm there
well let me tell you one thing that this
this makes me think about here's what it
makes me think about
you know what's the one country that's
got the
youngest population in the world what do
you think is the one country india
india 54 of india's population is below
25 years old let me say this one more
time
54 tom that's a big number 54
is you know how we have to baby boom
then we have the millennials the gen x
whatever
all these big booms 76 million baby
boomers 78 million in all these things
you talk about 54 below 25 years old who
do you think they're thinking about
what do you think china's thinking about
china's sitting there saying wait a
minute we've had the biggest population
for a long time
india's about to pass them up that's
number one that's going to happen next
you know decade or so when you pass them
up in population maybe it's going to
take a couple decades but they're going
to pass them out the way they're going
and they're sitting there saying if
those guys have a younger audience
younger talent pool that means
innovation is going to be higher
creativity is going to be higher
the energy to less is going to be higher
stamina is going to be higher
competition the willingness to compete
is going to be higher cost of labor
lower
everything is going to be higher for
india that gives them an edge i don't
know if they're sitting there in a room
and they're saying well let's do this
because
folks want to have more kids let's just
be noble and let's
let's let people have what they want i
don't think that's the case
isn't that a problem though like i mean
have we gone i mean i don't know i don't
want to
i don't want to take up you know the
reigns as the as the progressive here at
the table but
haven't we gone too far where we're
starting to talk about you know the cost
of raising a child outside of the
benefit like how much it costs we're
like
we our entire job as humans is to move
this thing forward well true but if you
have kids you're reminded of how
expensive they are every average i mean
he told me yesterday with his kids when
he pays to go to his kids for school and
i was like this is insanity
it can't be once you have kids that's
not average you don't make a decision
based on money but you can't help but
think about it
but then it's idiocracy then it just
then idiocracy goes from a movie to a
documentary then you just have dumb poor
people having more kids
no i don't know the perspective will
skew a little bit because you won't look
at it so scientifically
i'm looking at it as a what do you think
of a societal issue no i think it's a
fact that's all it is but i don't think
you
well you know what i think people do use
that fact and realize okay i think i
might be done now
right because i know the cost of the
kids it doesn't affect how you raise
them or how you feel about
nothing like that yeah but i mean you do
see there's it's a lot of money to raise
kids and it's even more interesting
million per from zero to 18.
and i'd say in a lot of cases it's a lot
higher right so that's absolutely
quarter million okay let me play devil's
advocate you're working anyway you're
earning anyway
what what else would you spend the money
on that would be more beneficial to you
and society
than raising a kid that has your core
values
we're not arguing against that i don't
think that's i will tell you though i
will tell i'll get
i'll tell you the opposite side i also
think there are some families that ought
to not have
as many kids as they have i also think
the current tax system
uh unfortunately influences some people
to have a lot of kids and take the
benefits and the welfare and the
payments that are being sent from the
government because if you have nine kids
you're making 400 per and you're getting
you know all these other benefits that
comes with it that's a salary to you
that's been paid out so
the tax system kind of favors people
having a lot of kids i'm not for
let's go have a lot of kids i'm not four
let's not have l
have any kids i'm for hey you think you
can afford three kids go ahead what
works for you you don't want to have any
i have friends that say
i have a friend i have a very we were
born a month apart me and this other
friend of mine okay
were born a month apart him and his wife
and his parents are convinced
the worst thing they can do is have kids
right now well he's lucky he married her
then because they have the same belief
both of them
don't want to have any kids they're he's
in his uh early 40s like me she's on her
interesting thing she hasn't flipped at
all and and the grandparents
are happy like meaning their parents
have no influence to say hey you gotta
have in their middle eastern it's like
you would at least say
and his parents only had one kid it's a
one-shot so they're not in the mindset
of
i know a lot of people today that don't
have kids but i think if you have the
money
and you want to be able to you know
leave a legacy beyond i think you ought
to have as many kids as you can
this should be a meme this should be a
meme for how expensive kids are
i was watching shark tank one time and
this guy walks into the tank right with
all that vigor and excitement they come
through the doors
he's fired up he's ready to give his
pitch tells the sharks he's got
eight kids eight kids right so he does
the thing he's trying to get the
investment yeah
shut out by everybody walks out no money
you should have seen the walk of shame
as he left that room knowing i got eight
kids and i didn't get that investment
i'm screwed he says
no you just keep doing it you just sent
it the other point with india too though
if you have 54 percent of the country
that you're trying to find
the tax revenue from these from this
generation they're going to be able to
build themselves up a lot quicker
listen i am so excited about india
this is the i've never i went to india
when you know the story two three years
ago we went to india we went to mumbai
and i spoke at iit with the chairwoman
of uh
state bank of india you know 240 000
employees
the desire to want to learn about
business and
entrepreneurship is insane you know how
i finished my message when i uh
spoke at in in india here's my message
yeah you actually got to watch what i
say at the end
my last 10 minutes was the following
here's what i said i said listen
students because there's politicians in
the room there's billionaires in the
room there's
government employees i said this is my
biggest recommendation to you
india right now you're hungry right now
you want to be like
america you want to compete against
america china i said
the next decade or two you're going to
make so much money
your country's going to become so rich
they're going to be able to create some
of the most incredible inventions that
the world's going to use
and then they're going to try to raise
taxes don't vote for it
i'm telling you in 20 years do not vote
for raising taxes
i'm telling you it's coming right just
say no yep and everybody starts laughing
and you see the politicians go like this
and i said thank you so much for my time
you know you're my god the way you
describe
india sounds to me a lot there seems to
be a lot of parallels or at least you
believe there to be a lot of parallels
to india and postwar japan you think
they're they're about to go through
a phase of industrialization that's
going to bring them out of the third
world
and then into the fortunate even more i
believe even more i believe you know the
by the way japan right now is the
country with the most
debt uh their debt ratio today in india
it's it's a scare they're number one
above everybody okay then they have less
than ten percent of the population of
india too
it's it's a scary thought what's going
on but you got a innovation auto so many
different industries they crossed
70s 80s and 90s absolutely they came in
u.s and they were one of the best things
and they raised taxes
and then they raised taxes so the thing
with india here's the thing with india
in business when i left bali total
fitness
and i went to bali's and my boss robbie
told me if you do
xyz you're going to be able to leave
chatsworth
the gym i didn't want to be in are you
going to be able to go to hollywood and
be the weekend manager
i said who do i have to beat he said
edwin guerra
i beat edwin guerra in a smaller club he
said if you beat him you got the job in
sales
in sales i beat edwin guerrero i was
ranked number eight edwin now was number
10.
he comes and says i have to have a
meeting with you i'm like i know what
he's meeting with i'm dressed up nice i
got my
crease back in the days i would crease
my own shirts i would crease everything
right
so i'm coming in i'm like robbie's here
come meet with me he's going to give me
the goodness so patrick let's go sit in
the back
hey buddy someone tell you great job
last month phenomenal job i'm so proud
of you the way you're going right now
wonder you're going to be a supervisor
at bali's
and but i need you to stay here because
no one's been able to turn this club
around more than you
and we need you here and i said i'm
sorry
you told me to beat edwin garrison i
said did you see the leaders bulletin
let me show you
he says no i've seen it already i said
that's my job he says look he's been
here
and i'm giving a job to him said wait a
minute wait what i'm giving a job to him
he gives the job to him
i said why to him he says tenure he's
been here with us for six years
you've been here for us with us nine
months you know what i said i mean i
said i quit
that moment by the way i can't quit yeah
i don't i'm like i don't know what i'm
used to the job
i quit don't leave jobs they leave
bosses here's what's crazy robbie robbie
helped me get very good in sales and
he's actually a very good guy but that
decision whether it came from him
or from a guy above him it is what it is
here's the point i'm trying to make the
point i'm trying to make is
valleys equals india today india needs
some laws india needs some strong law
schools
india needs to have some uh what do you
call it some level of confidence to give
where a smaller person who's coming up
to be able to compete they can't be
bullied by the big guy there's still a
lot of corruption going on in india
if you ask the small entrepreneur that's
coming up what their biggest fear is
there's a level of corruption taking
place there if they if they can fix that
yeah
where there's trust in the system and i
can compete fairly
and if i lose i lose then there's going
to be some good innovation taking place
what's the plan there because
sound this sounds almost exactly what
china has in mind for
africa especially south africa so guess
what's the youngest country in the world
top 10 youngest countries in the world
i'm going to say south africa it's all
africa
really top ten yeah so look what china
is doing china's going over there
all that money to compete we need to
compete on that continent in ways that
we are not competing that silk road is
going to change the youngest
top 10 is that because of the mortality
in africa people die old are younger
so then the the people are younger
there's lots of old people good point
maybe good point
anyway hey the thing that scares me a
little bit about india though is the
level of poverty
kind of festering before an opportunity
for socialism to come in there
that's what scares me because there are
there really is a huge discrepancy
in that country but you know i'm
surprised they haven't evolved a little
bit more athletically
in sports haven't become a little bit
more of a world power with that type of
population
in american sports they're not good but
in uh what would that
in eastern sports they do pretty well
they do pretty well with cricket it just
hasn't been a priority
well we'll see what's going to happen
here all i know is folks in china are
probably making babies right now what's
that what's that guy
the barry bonds of india he's going to
be so mad he's definitely listening
to this as sanjeev the guy hits like
nine
home runs what are they calling they
don't call them home runs over there
they call them like uh
cricket yeah it's uh they they call them
uh oh
outs i think they call them outs yeah
it's a cricket if you i played baseball
cricket's ridiculous and so what's the
longest hormone you ever hit
uh like 540 feet 500 wide 540 that's
mickey mantle
yeah yeah wow yeah what what level what
where play the double a
okay yeah i i was a one tool guy i could
run into a fastball every now and then
do something now that's
awesome yeah that was pretty much it
yeah but by the way if you see a swing
yeah she had a real nice swing
yeah he's got a real nice i would
imagine you could just why don't we pull
why don't we pull up the bench press why
don't you pull up the bench press video
if you got it
okay so so so before we look at this
folks what do you think this man bench
pressed what do you think this man
bench press yesterday i want you to
comment below what do you think
our friend here gerard michaels bench
press last night comment below while
you're doing that
tom did you you said 325 right is that
what i said i said you guys know the
answer or no you know what he benched or
no you know what he been sure no you
haven't
what do you think he benched last night
uh i'll do
400. oh you're going to go 400. so you
think he had fallen that's a big number
by the way thank you sam do you know the
answer or no
thank you all right kyle don't you pull
up the video let's take a look
hi by the way we both worked a 12-hour
day yesterday kai did not want to come
to the gym
3 45's though those are 4 45 plates
that's that's actually well you got to
know
those are bigger than so you're looking
at is that the 515
that's 405. that's 405. okay let's take
a look at 405. go ahead
let's take a look at 405. i'm used to
being a big guy by the way this redcon
won i might have been one of the
smallest people in the gym look at his
places look how he picks it up
oh my god you're doing it for reps yeah
um 405. that's three
four four times so that's not max that
was a warm-up
that's a warm-up four times right he
benched
four plates 405. now we can't listen to
the audio because they're playing music
for uh uh look at how jack the guys are
in the back
how are you never an offensive guard in
football i was i was
i was a linebacker 5 15 here 5 15.
5 5 25 5 25 check this out 5 25.
you ready 5 25. nice short spot
i don't count anyone
oh my gosh 5 25.
are you kidding me yeah he picked up 525
that's impressive
even if the spot was say 20 pounds of
spots
he said he could curl seventy five
pounds eighty eighty five pounds ninety
i didn't know
and then i did uh you know barbell did
two oh five you did 90 how many times
once
just one yeah let's see that's 90. yeah
that's impressive i can do the perfect
push-up that's it that's impressive man
just don't ask me to run a mile you know
i'll be good there you go okay so
515 pounds 500 plus pounds
bench press that's pretty impressive
it's hard it's hard to believe that
you're looking at peak
physical performance there is is what i
mean this is
it you know people think like you know
models
and uh the rock nuts this is this is the
mark henry physique is what we're going
for
listen this is weight boy summer is what
we're going for here
oh no no no the the the your clothes
your dress attire it's just very unique
matter to you did the the number they
had longer arms so for me
long arms it's uh it's uh but you know
max i did was 385
and when i was mentioning 85 and 64 is
really good 385 64.
300 was that magic number for me you
could just get it over 300 yeah
305 i got one now i could do two plays
25 times i could do it too like you know
how you going
to combine yeah the nfl combine that's
what they do that's how they measure you
that's right they wanted to place 25
times i could do pull-ups you know 40
times on my peak
40 times that's what i could do yeah the
bodyweight exercises are the best if you
can do that
so but again props to gerard 500
and how about the prediction of 400 back
there strong respect you win by the way
if we're playing what's the game
not wheel of fortune if we're playing uh
oh if the price is right price is right
you win you win you win a prize
congratulations new camper yes okay all
right so let's go to
folks if you're listening to this we're
still doing the super chat 10x bonus
which means
whatever you put if it's a good comment
question that we use
i may even get some callers in if you
got some strong opinions about something
and you're an expert in it we had a
couple people that are cops in chicago
send me a message
telling me they want to get on to give
us some feedback about what chicago is
really like but that person is on a
flight right now
to hawaii uh for vacation with his
family anybody that puts a super chat we
pick you so you put ten dollars we're
going to give you 10 times back
wait somebody gives you 10 bucks you
give them a hundred dollars i give a
hundred dollars hey people
we listen we pay people super chats
we gave a couple thousand on a couple
episodes ago so folks that's the super
chat
question comments we can't see everybody
but if you put a super chat we're taking
a little longer
i got to get a bot going to ask
questions yes
okay all right let's get into it so
stories trump is telling people he
thinks he'll be reinstated as president
in august okay page five
let's start off with a soft story
nothing you know it's just there
oh boy this is a business insider cool
cool
just a coup all right trump is telling
people he thinks he'll be reinstated as
president
on august business insider's story trump
has been telling people things will
attend white house as a sitting
president by august the new york times
reporter maggie
haberman tweeted on tuesday haberman who
broke some of the biggest stories of the
trump administration and has been
covering him
for decades added that trump has been
laser focused on election audits and
states where results he is still trying
to overturn
the anti-democratic conspiracy theory
has been bubbling
up in the french conservative media for
several months it has no basis under the
constitution or any legitimate legal
framework my pelosi or mike lindell has
been
a prominent pro proponent of the theory
the former trump attorney sydney powell
also floated the idea
at a q anon conference which is also
called the
gateway pundit conference over the
weekend
thoughts oh man i gotta tell you uh well
i i hope he's right but on the other
hand man i think they they stole it fair
and square at some point you just have
to
you've got to learn and uh they
they know what they did they are slow
rolling out
their excuses they've now started using
the term fortifying the election
they didn't steal the election they
fortified the election right
and you have that that new york times
i'm sorry was a
time magazine article that detailed
step by step how they did it and what
they did and when i say they this is not
just the democrats by the way
this is the cheney republicans the bush
faction the neocons
the quote unquote swamp all the war
hawks that wanted us
and and again it tells you everything
you need to know about why biden was
put in power by the powers that be that
after a year and a half of holding the
country
political hostage before they gave a
single stimulus check to any american
they gave 250 million dollars to
raytheon and started dropping bombs on
syria
tells you all you need to know about
what washington prioritizes and what
they don't
and trump wasn't giving them their their
blood money trump wasn't
sending people overseas to die and they
didn't like that
so they got rid of them and they did it
legally though
see they did steal the election but they
did it legally
they did it it may be corrupt but it was
legally corrupt what they did in georgia
what they did
in in pennsylvania they changed the
election laws
specifically to allow them to cheat if
anything
i blame republicans for not being
willing to play in the mud
right the if if the democrat dead can
vote
why can't the republican dead vote you
have to do what you have to do to win
i'm so sick and tired
of republicans talking you really
believe that's what happened absolutely
i'm so sick and freaking tired of
republicans wanting to be like well we
did things the right way we were noble
no you lost
at some point if you keep losing you're
not noble you're a sucker
you know what i'm saying like if they
keep changing the rules and you keep
playing by their rules that they don't
even play
by you're not noble you're a sucker well
here's the question are they going to be
able to adapt if that's the different
game plan now that's what we're going to
find out get out
for once we'll see if they're that
visionary you know in a related story to
this one did you hear about nancy pelosi
she says she's going to be the captain
of the laker girls next year
all right that has about as much
relevance yes i am
because it's it's about it he was about
to say i had all of these glitches
you never know what this was like yeah
lebron might say i'm i'm mandating this
you know you know here's the thing this
is why
i truly believe trump's not running
again because
say what you want about him i don't
think he's a complete idiot and would he
want a message like this
out there i mean really this just sounds
so preposterous and so ridiculous
and there's no one with half a brain
cell that actually believes that it's
physically
everything about it is impossible by the
way i'm more interested in the other
trump that's in the news this week
donald trump jr he's hilarious did you
hear he's on cameo now do you know what
he's charging for his videos he's
charging
600 bucks 600 to get a video from uh
donald trump jr he says they need the
money because of all the attacks
from new york absolutely you know from
the attorney general and whatnot so
here's the funniest thing about donald
trump junior's bio
on cameo right for his profile he lists
themselves as a new york times
best-selling author
i mean why would you use the new york
times to
you know to to prop you up when all you
do is rail on them i would i wouldn't i
would take that line out of there but
yeah you know trump just has to
isn't there a rally this week too i
think there's a rally so you know the
crazy big bitcoin
miami there's a bitcoin biggest ever 50
000 are in miami this week
it's a bunch of parties that we're being
invited to i may attend one i don't know
yet i may attend one
uh the only reason i'm saying i may not
because i got you know next week is a
pretty crazy week for us and we're gone
but uh
uh yeah we made so look here's here's
what i think about this year okay here's
what i think about this year
so play there's three parties here
number one okay
number one is he's out of his mind
there's no the key word they use which
is their fear
it says it has no it has no basis under
the constitution of any
legitimate legal framework okay so
that's that part so
somebody may say well for decades they
couldn't take the mob out
until somebody came and taught at a
university hey
we wrote this law in here called the
rico law
why don't you guys know so they brought
the attorneys and you know the story
they brought the attorneys and
they trained the attorneys on how to
take the mob down then the attorneys
went out and there was this young
assistant attorney general his name is
mr rudy giuliani we're gonna go after
them
he hires three attorneys to work with
them out of 150 attorneys he had to
choose from the three attorneys he
chooses guess how all these guys are
29 29 30 years old he brings
young bucks who don't have a lot of
experience and they say hey guys they
don't stand on ceremonies
no no they're just like let's just go
figure this thing but they have energy
right and they go
so meaning one end if there's creative
attorneys to be able to figure out
if there's something out there they can
do more power to them second thing
if giuliani is the guy that found the
rico law
and trump hired him and he was charging
around 400 grand a month by the way when
when uh giuliani was good money this was
a year ago
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so if he hires
them for 400
dollars a month four hundred thousand
dollars a month and all they can get was
a landscaping place
that's the point so if that happened and
nothing was able to be figured out
what is that so all these states kemp
georgia all of these things that was
coming back arizona you know hey
they are finding stuff it's just the
democrats have more attorneys they did
things
to the letter of the law after they
changed the law did you hear the one
story came out that one of the
mafia members got three million dollars
and 30 000
uh 30 000 what do you call it ballots to
put in oh yeah did you hear about that
story
no here's here's here's what's going on
how about the boxes that were taken away
nobody ever wanted to talk about that
they literally showed the boxes being
taken
off the table put under the table like
it's insanity listen
you know you're talking about a couple
things here we talked about this
yesterday i think it's important for the
audience to be thinking about this so
here's a few things just a hundred years
ago okay just 100 years ago gambling was
illegal
yes just 100 years ago gambling was
illegal the first casino
legal casino that came out in new york
was what year seven 1978 the year i was
born right
first one in atlantic city right okay in
92 i think it was fox haven
fox whatever kinetic shout out
yeah that's shout out to greg dinkins
research for us which
was very helpful next so gambling was
illegal the mob was doing it illegally
uh online sports betting was illegal
there was no bookies this was five years
ago this is
five years what i'm talking about a
hundred years ago ago 50 years ago
bookies that were only ran by the mob
and gangsters you go to uh
uh you know loan sharks you know you
were going out there and doing
loan sharking i give you a thousand
dollars but you got to give me thirteen
hundred dollars back in a month that's
thirty percent
that's gonna pay the loans that's
student loans that's student loans
then you have drugs that was being sold
you know illegally
now amazon is supporting marijuana
and by the way do not do do you think in
the next year two years three years
amazon's gonna be selling
uh marijuana on their website bothers me
to know
so they just figured that out so they're
going to the point i'm trying to make to
use
all of these things were illegal just 50
years ago
now they're multi multi multi billion
dollar industries that we're talking
about right so so the government
and a lot of these fortune 100 companies
took their ideas from the mob
they're doing it so maybe a lot of these
political parties are sitting there
saying listen man the mob
the people control elections for a long
time hey maybe we ought to go pick up
some of these playbooks and they're
using it and it's working no doubt
but who knows if it's happening but
who's the ringleader on the republican
side to actually
organize that's the problem so divided
look up if you want to look up something
look up color revolution if you want to
know what happened in america look up
color revolution what's
what should scare you about that when
people talk about the quote-unquote deep
state
and you get into the conspiracy theories
it's not a conspiracy
that there are cia operatives and fbi
operatives that are
partisans that have actively tried to
uh circumvent our duly elected
process okay they're on record both cia
and
fbi and they've done this in other
places when people talk about
they hate us because of our freedoms
people around the world hate us because
no
they hate us because we do [ __ ] like
this to their elections all the time
we interfere in these elections
overseas all the time the way our deep
state interfered in our election this
time
we do this across the world but by the
way we got a bunch of activity that took
place and people want us to talk about
the fouchy emails paul
lee brandt gave a hundred dollars so can
we talk about the voucher emails little
rock a hundred dollars i was a russian
linguistic linguist in army during the
80s i was a truck driver during
uh working through undergrad i have a bs
and an ms an electric computer
engineering i'm now a lawyer and cannot
understand how anyone believes fauci
after the his mask fiasco what do you
think about emails
little rock why don't you text us at
310-340-1132 send us a text at 310-340
and let us know your little rock and
we'll see what we can do here but so
look here's all i'm saying to you is
if if if if the folks on the left or the
right got more creative to win
salute if they broke the law score they
got to be held accountable but if they
figured it i figured out a way to get
away with it
you were creative what what what did our
president say our sitting president the
the most popular president of all time
by the way got more votes than both
donald trump
and barack obama can't put a full sent
coaching sentence together
greatest campaigners of all time
greatest campaign
he he spoke at least once a month on the
campaign trail guy was tireless
got a top-notch son man hunter
again again but there's there's no
corruption in the in our fbi at all
none uh all right yeah what did he say
though patrick and this and this should
scare them because if they're trying to
go with that last line that you said is
there that's their line of defense
that's the mainstream
there's no constitutional what did what
did joe biden say
didn't joe biden i don't forget what the
exact quote was it was something like
there's nothing in the constitution
that's that that that's forever
everything in the constitution oh
when he was talking about stacking the
court everything in the constitution is
available to change
my leg hair and pop popeyes was bad dude
yeah this is reaching out on the inside
of my leg
they used to braid my hair uh i have
hope and optimism i think there's enough
people that might be okay
you know good people i don't think you
can keep this secret if if
laws were broken i don't think so i
think eventually over time
eventually yes but what's eventually uh
years unfortunately
give me a timeout two to three years i
mean i disagree no
there's so many people involved i don't
think it ever does i i
one of the most fun i think it's 30
years see that's why i believe we went
to the next generation
it's a legacy for sure i think it's 30
years you're going to the movies you're
sitting there saying no freaking when
kids are like that would never happen
we're like we lived through this
but it's a movie 30 years from now kind
of like argo explaining what happened in
youtube
yeah yeah but it's the most sorry the
most the most
just because it goes on this the most
formative book i've ever read in my life
the book that i read that most
formed my my world view is the gulag
archipelago
all right by alexander soshnichkin right
and his
one of his biggest lines if you don't
have you ever read the google log
archipelago
he wrote this while he was in the gulak
he was a political dissident in congress
his book pull up this book so people
can't see what he's talking about he had
to hide it he wrote this over the course
of 10 years while he was a political
prisoner
he had to write it and then he published
it it was illegal
it was punishable by 10 years hard labor
in russia if you were caught reading
this book when it came out in 1978
and it it describes all of the horrors
of far leftist communist tyrannical
governments and and how it represses
freedom
and one of the lines in the very
beginning of the book is
we know they are lying they know that we
know
they are lying we know that they know
that we know they are lying
and yet still they continue to lie and
that is the power say that one more time
say that one more time we know they're
lying okay this is alexander stolzness
yep
we know they're lying they know that we
know
that they're lying we know that they
that we know they are lying and yet
still they continue to lie
powerful that is the power principle
powerful
that's the gall of the powerful they'll
do whatever if they did whatever it
takes to get power
now they have to do whatever it takes to
keep it
there you go so in reality i think what
we're all saying is nothing's going to
change
this election unless we change it no but
with the next three years do you think
anything's going to change what's the 50
50 senate and yeah this midterm is going
to be a bloodbath
how about you this midterm it has to be
it has to be a ground war
yeah but do you think it's gonna flip do
you think the house is gonna fly i i
think
in order to make the house flip you have
to match what they're doing you have to
take their place then you gotta start
now because the elections next year it
needed
it needed to start it didn't start two
years ago when their action front
how much is trump needed for that how
much does trump need to get
back and forth that's a great question i
go back and forth because he riles up
his side
but he also activates the other side and
that's something where like desantis
i think activates his side without
activating the other side i i it's a
really really interesting question
this could win i do i'd i especially
think a a coalition of desantis and a
tulsi
or a desantis and a mansion and it it
won't happen
for reasons but i tell you a coalition
party like that a coalition where the
santa claus sanction
oh my god comes up don't forget tulsi
comes over look what tulsi did
to kamala twice already she would she
would have to debate kamala again
if she was the vp here's the problem
with trump um he could empower
a big flip in the house if he could he
can't think small that's his problem so
if you were equated to an actor all he
can think about is being in a
blockbuster
movie and winning an academy award he's
not going to go off broadway he doesn't
give a damn about that same thing in
baseball he wants to play in the world
series
doesn't care about the minor leagues he
could get a ground swell of support to
help flip the house
and be and be a real force that way but
all he can think about and all he can
talk about is
they're going to reinstate me in august
he's only thinking about the biggest
prize
when they actually could use the power
that he has on the ground level
he's also to your point at 60 minutes
he's going to talk 59 minutes of that is
going to be powerful his base is going
to be happy he's going to say
one thing in 60 minutes that's going to
be a sound bite that again
is then used and played to activate the
other side it's going to it's going to
be manipulated he can't help himself but
being edgy and and he he wants that
sound bite he wants
to dominate the news cycle he thinks in
in terms of media
and again what what's sun tzu what does
sun tzu say right never never stop your
enemy when he's defeating himself
like that that's what he does all the
time the best thing the republicans have
done
in the last two years is shut up and let
people hear what democrats are actually
saying right
let them hear what you're actually
saying like whoa what's this green new
deal
hold on if i give you all my money
you're gonna change the weather
like wait you know what trump has to
worry because you talk about playing
dirty that district attorney in new york
will do whatever she possibly can to
take him down absolutely and i think
that's his biggest
battle right now he's got some some
serious issues on the legal front by the
way any thoughts on him taking down his
blog
page six go to page six let's talk about
this so he takes on his blog
and everyone's talking about it trump's
blog page shut down for a good cnbc
story former president donald trump's
blog a webpage where he shared
statements after larger social media
companies banned for their platforms has
been permanently shut down his
spokesperson said on wednesday
the page from the desk of donald j trump
has been scrubbed
from trump's website after going live
less than a month earlier it will not be
returning his senior aide jason miller
told cnbc
when asked online later wednesday
whether the move was a pr
a precursor to the former president
joining another social media platform
milo replied
yes actually it is stay tuned since
leaving the office on january 20th
former president who
strongly hinted he may run for
presidential 2024 has just made a
handful of
in-person appearances and has
participated in interviews
only with friendly media outlets
thoughts
uh i i think it makes a lot of sense
from a marketing standpoint pull it away
i've ran a blog if anybody here's ever
blogged it is actually pretty difficult
and it's not very fruitful
um so you know i think in this what ends
up happening with blogs too
is when you're used to getting a million
interactions when you're not getting
those interactions it it becomes
it becomes a cumbersome to do it you're
almost like it's like showing up to a
party that nobody's at
how many times do you go to a club and
there's nobody in the club and you keep
going to that club yeah
so you just stop going you pull yourself
away a little bit you know i've heard
you talk about this a lot you say some
of the best things that you can do is
disappear for a little while
disappear for a little while let people
you know let let the
the market kind of appreciate for for
you and your voice and your services
again
and then when you come back come back
big i think that that's kind of what
he's doing yeah he was completely
neutered without social media he's an
instantaneous guy he wants immediate
impact immediate reaction he couldn't
get that with a blog
they had no they'd have to have an army
of people pushing that out that have
access to social media i mean it felt
like he was writing handwritten notes
with a feathered pen
and then throwing them out with a
carrier pigeon it was so archaic it just
didn't work they keep talking about this
new social media platform
it better be i would shut up about it
because he also there are their people
are also saying he's going to be
reinstated as president
you're losing credibility with these
statements i don't i personally don't
believe
there's some magical social media
platform now there might be a platform
but not
access to the two billion or millions
and billions i want him to try yeah we
need
we need another platform i do want him
to try it but i agree it has to come out
there has to be some real evidence that
there's this new social media platform
under yeah under promise over
performance either this is a method
because one of the four media giant
social media virtual governments is
about to let them back on
either there's talks behind closed doors
that either facebook
youtube twitter somebody's listening
okay i'm just saying although although
he made twitter a ton of money he did
but all i'm saying is there may be talks
behind closed doors that one of them
is open to the idea and i think you know
you know who i think would be actually
open to the idea
i think it would probably be youtube who
would be open to the idea in google
and then it would probably be facebook
last for me it's going to be uh what do
you call it
uh uh twitter okay yeah so i just don't
by the way dorsey's in town right now
with miami for the bitcoin deal that's
taking place yeah
so you know on that part it is what it
is this is the other thing to be
thinking about
there's a lot of things trump's done and
after a month two months doesn't work
out it's like
you know that's true he's done this his
entire career people are surprised it's
steak boom cut it
airline cut it boom cut it boom the guy
does this
his entire life and people are surprised
and here's the reality of it
he still keeps winning the guy
keeps still winning figuring out ways to
win look the last 12 months are probably
not the best 12 months of his career i
think it's fair to say yeah the last
homes are not the best 12 months of his
career
but the guy is still number 45 it's
going to be forever
the guy still became a billionaire the
guy still got the real estate market in
manhattan to go to a whole different
direction the guy had a show on tv that
was a
best-selling show for years the guy went
on oprah winfrey in the 80s and said one
day
if i ran for president i'd win because
i'm a winner who the hell predicts 40
years prior to
there's a lot simpson made an episode
about the guy becoming a president
walking down the esk i mean there's a
lot of stuff that you talk about here
the point is the following
don't ever underestimate a person with
74 years of experience
having dealt in the streets of new york
during the era of the mob doing real
estate
construction winning losing media
marriage scandal after scandal person
all of that stuff you're going to
underestimate somebody like that
no yeah the guy's got a lot of
experience have you guys seen the
documentary the four-part documentary on
netflix on trump's lives oh that was
horrible
did you think so well i mean i like the
fact that they had all this archaic or
this uh
this uh that's a for footage everything
he has done in his life
is documented i think we're thinking of
something different well it was not
positive no
but it was interesting if you go in
there with an open mind it's fun just to
see
you know the life he lived in the 70s
80s and 90s you know let me ask you this
question do you think there's
any do you think the tech companies are
in any real danger
of government regulation of them
actually being able to do something and
could any heat be directed to them right
now meaning
hey the first thing you have to do is
let him back on and then maybe this will
delay the inevitable before
let me ask you a question i'm going to
ask you a question every year a decade
and you tell me okay
um who who was a
you know a person who was winning
most fee scared of uh i don't know in
the 50s
in the 60s what do you mean you know so
for example if you're in the streets of
new york who are you most scared of in
the 60s 70s 80s
uh the mob okay the mob okay okay go
into
90s 2000 who were you most scared of in
the 80s and in the 90s and 2000s if
you're coming up like
oh my gosh if they write a story about
me i'm screwed hillary clinton
no national inquiry yeah there you go
newspaper national but it was
newspaper yeah national enquirer and
maybe the
the little bit of the media tv the cable
news who are you scared of today if you
say the wrong thing
companies right social media today's mob
is the tech company
they we talked to they de-platformed me
yeah today's mob
is they is the tech company and people
are actually scared today now here's the
thing
when you're powerful the challenge with
power is the following
you think it's forever and unfortunately
it's not forever
especially if your power is not
inspiration
if your power is based on control and
fear
if it's driven based on control and fear
it's never going to be forever
if your power is based on freedom
choice influence you know example
inspiration you know
aspiration there's a vision we're
chasing and you're somebody like that
that can last a long time but this
methodology of having power
is gonna have so much resistance it's
not gonna last forever it just doesn't
no
history tells you no matter how big you
are history doesn't favor you if you
lead the way you're leading
and especially when we have a history of
freedom in this country yeah right and
you know what there's just such a
craving right now for common sense
you can kind of sense it out there
people people are becoming
onto this and that's why i was saying
you know with all the
hands that had to be involved in the
wheel if anything you know did take
place that wasn't legitimate
there's too many it's too hard to keep a
secret in this country it's too hard to
keep doing something if you're not being
i remember
authenticity what am i telling what have
i i've been preaching to you we are
entering the era
of authenticity if you are not in real
life
who you pretend to be you have no future
in media in this country we are entering
an era where people just don't want to
deal
with liars cheats thiefs and crooks
and that's not that they don't have you
don't have a place
because there is a place for that but i
think people are going to figure you out
that's the biggest i've been in business
now for 20 years
there were some times where i was going
up against an opponent where
my peers flipped on me and they would
say well you know he's saying this and
maybe he's right about you
and i'm like no matter what i say in
that moment i don't have
anything to say because that guy had a
bigger platform let's just say right
yeah and then all of a sudden a year
went by two years three years and like
shoot look and the way you treat
everybody then all of a sudden there's
five people saying no this is how he
does business 10 people saying no this
is how
50 people no never have five thousand
ten thousand then people say
what are you talking about you're just a
hater yeah so then long
term those become qualified haters and
everyone knows it totally once you fall
into that category let me tell you
that's permanent
if you envy somebody's success and that
person's success you have to watch
because who knows more about who knows
more about our day-to-day than you guys
who knows more about it like who knows
more about what goes on in valuetainment
than the two of you
like how often are you here mario but
but what do you do you see what happens
in vitamin every day
yeah what happened yes you see it you
work it you've been here
day night last six seven eight months so
you see what's going on right
if somebody wanted to know how
valuetainment's culture is what did they
say
not ask me ask who the people that ask
you sure ask kai yeah ask the people
that are here right
if you want to know that the approach
you're taking the fake side
you can't do that forever yeah you will
be exposed you have to you're going to
be expecting something
to your point here you know where you
were saying that people will understand
it and there's a market for it but you
can ignore it i mean i look at myself
there was nothing more important to me
than local news you know for 15 years i
was in the middle all i cared about was
moving to the next big market
you know getting big big interviewed
everybody michael jordan kobe bryant you
name it
and and i watched the news all day i
mean if it was on the news it was
important it was relevant it was real
was it
you know you had to believe it i don't
watch local news anymore not only that i
do not watch it
if there was the only reason i would
watch the local news is if there was an
earthquake in l.a
and maybe they wouldn't be lying at that
point it is such a great point it is
such a great point
we are uh there's a podcast not to give
not not to give free uh
free advertising out there but there's a
podcast called uh the dark horse podcast
and it's brett weinstein
and his wife and they they're phenomenal
it's it's not the easiest listen
they're two professors they speak very
very quietly it's a little npr
but they're brilliant and what he says
is essentially our he's an evolutionary
biologist and he says our brains
have not learned to interpret the
television as anything other than the
window to the outside world
so we still look at the television the
way a thousand years ago a medieval
person would look outside the window and
see barbarians at the gate
so even though like george floyd
horrible horrible thing that happened to
george floyd
horrible thing that that derek shoving
did to george floyd
but in reality the fact that that
somehow became indicative of america
where everybody in the world everybody
in the world
got so upset about a person that they've
never met in a place that they've never
been
that it became a a a benchmark a pillar
moment for our society and and nobody's
ever been there
nobody ever knew this guy nobody's ever
been there and we all acted like this
happened to our best friend down the
block i'm from minnesota
are you really i was just there last
week yeah
i played for the second year but
the uh but but the point i'm trying to
make is that if
if we are so focused and we are now
we're so connected globally
and if we are all focused on the worst
[ __ ] that's happening
to people every single day there's
there's bad things happening to people
every day around the world we're
forgetting like humans
are killing it we're doing so good we
went from
we went from horse and buggy to the
freaking moon
in 70 years like we're crushing it the
bit like the biggest problem that we
have in in our world
they say climate change and then after
that is overpopulation
we're so good at living not enough of us
dying
poverty is down right people that live
in america
like up just above the poverty line
today they
live a quantifiably better life than
18th century royalty
they have cars they have air
conditioning they have access to
nutrition on a level that only royalty
had
300 years ago but because like you're
saying we're so
global in our thinking that all we do
especially people who are naturally
anxious that have anxiety they wake up
every day oh my god the world is ending
because
somebody halfway across the world had
some bad things happen but if the news
tells you the world is ending 24
7 i mean you're gonna be thinking the
world is ending so
consuming the media turn it loose yeah i
mean sometimes
sometimes you just have to turn
everything off like you said turn
everything off to just calm your nerves
come back at it when you're a little bit
more calm but going back to what you
said
uh it sounds like you wanted to say well
i was just gonna say have your own
opinion do not rely on these pinheads on
the news
because they don't give a damn about you
and they don't even know what's going on
in the world all right they have a focus
and a plan each day of what they're
going to do
the situation head on the news a former
good head they're not involved
you know the george floyd situation is
just collateral for the news it's just
something that they can use and leverage
for the next year
that's it and you know the other thing
too is we bash tech we bash these media
or
like uh tech companies but how great is
google
i mean i could not live without it yeah
i mean it is i would almost say it's the
greatest invention of all time
gmail and everything and and same thing
with apple how much do we take that for
granted
the technology that we have with that so
every day my point is
make up your own mind try to stay
informed as much as you can but if
you're
on one side or the other don't just
listen to that voice it's just gonna
make things worse tom that's part of the
arrogance of gen z
that's part of the arrogance of gen z
that they they think they're the
smartest people who've ever lived
because they have access to more
information than anybody else by the way
i like what nicholas maru said he said
if principles and values
were a priority today we wouldn't have
this problem
dems republicans is like a methodology
today
it is tribalism and to win at all costs
most of the officials have honorable
in front of their name you know you're
you're just kind of sitting there you're
wondering
half the battle is let's take a side to
republican democrat go through the top
20 issues and ask people where you stand
with it and then you know you kind of
fight for that rather than if you're
them you have to be a loyalist to it
nicholas gave 20 dollars nicholas i'm
giving you 10 times back so nicholas
gets 200 dollars kyle
let's make a note of that and then this
lady here who works
at uh luz acosta pandolfi
uh gave 50 i work in florida state
government and i have seen desantis's
policies
are changing hardcore dems minds and
perception of him and his way of
governing
our state in a positive way lose do you
mind sending a tax
to zero one one 310-340-113 two three
one zero three four zero one one three
two
and let us know what you do what kind of
business you what kind of job do you do
there and then i may get you on a call
here
so you know so those are the two colors
again folks if you're listening to this
you give a super chat we may do 10x back
on you if it's a comment question that
we may use
and we may even get you to call in here
go ahead tomorrow i was just going to
say this
topic that we're talking about just has
so many tentacles into every other topic
that we want to talk about today when
you look at gen
z or gen whatever it is and you that
story where they say 40
of people don't want to go back to work
if you have to go back to the office i
mean
if or the other thing too is we we are
in so much danger right now because we
think each other is our enemy
and then you look at the alignment of a
russia and a china and an iran
and they know damn well who their enemy
is there's one and they go at them every
single day they wake up
with a poster of them on the wall and
that's all they think about and that's
why we're so vulnerable right
is there a simpsons episode that says
trump's gonna die in august of 2021
is there a simpsons episode kai do you
know that or no can you better buy that
yes
just because they go away this guy just
says
jimmy marino the simpsons are a non-stop
mandela effect
let me check this out but go ahead you
were saying something and that's it i
pretty much said it no no
i can't believe the simpsons has been on
since 1987. but to tom's point and this
actually goes back to something
pat you said two episodes ago when i was
on you you talked about how
kind of the right fell asleep at the
wheel while the dems had a uh
in the really the far left not the dems
they they had a plan
to take over the ideological
epicenter of america they had a plan to
take over the colleges
yeah the media right and and that is
something it's not just the republicans
what what that commenter said he's right
it was just normal everyday americans
everybody else
was worried about trying to make it
trying to trying to feed their kids and
build a life for themselves
while there was a far-left ideological
religion
essentially that decided that they're
going to come in and they're going to
steal the robes in america they're going
to steal the robes they're going to
steal the courts
they're going to steal the judges
they're going to steal the professors
and then
they're going to own the next 100 years
from that and that comes specifically
from
mao's red book it comes specifically
from china china is investing all this
stuff you talk about russia
they're investing in this
decentralization of american values
that's not a conspiracy that that is
that is
actually taking place but i just looked
at that episode about simpsons it was
last year august 27
2020 not this year he outlasted them so
what i will say
all right and and this goes back back to
the gen z and you talked about how 40
of people don't want to go to work and i
believe if i'm correct it's something
like 45
of people under 30 view socialism in a
in a positive light again this is
because normal quote-unquote normal
people who engage in capitalism on a
day-to-day we don't spend
time explaining the values of capitalism
and why outside of valuetainment we
don't explain
like how capitalism like they hate
imperialism
capitalism ended imperialism we don't
have to go into mexico
and take them over anymore we can open
starbucks and mcdonald's and extract
wealth in exchange for value we don't
like lebron james
hates you know structural racism he
became a billionaire
by pla by by playing ball and hole that
didn't exist 200 years ago
in order for him to have raised himself
and in order for him to have raised
himself out of poverty
and socially stratified himself 200 300
years ago he would have had to kill
hundreds of thousands of people
he would have had to conquer he would
have had to have been a conquistador
he would have had to travel somewhere
else and take their stuff
but now he can acquire that wealth and
he can acquire that magnitude and that
status
by playing bowling pole be better okay
they need him tonight like like
professionals by the way less than 100
years what he's talking about it didn't
exist 100 years ago
the guy's a billionaire playing about a
game you're a billionaire playing a game
he would have
been a captain of the industry worried
about whether they should let their kids
play video games or not because maybe if
they don't let their kids play a video
game today it's an esport
kids are making millions of dollars
playing video games it's a completely
different world we're living in
a video game is a sport yes 40 30 years
ago like just stop playing video games
stop playing
today you're like [ __ ] that video game's
like playing basketball it's a sport
why is it a bad thing mobster kids they
wanted to make it big they wanted to
make millions of dollars too
instead of playing an esport they went
out and robbed people they jacked people
they tried they did the lufthansa heist
what if henry hill
had esports he wanted you know what i'm
saying like these aren't necessarily bad
things
we are the least violent and the most
productive generation in the history of
our species
in the history of our species of media
disagrees with you
yeah they're full of it they think
you're you're crazy you have no clue
what you're talking
you know what and they can say it to my
face because even though i benched 500
pounds
we live in the first time in the history
of humanity i can't just kill them to
shut them up
yeah 300 years ago i'd kill them and
take their stuff you got
oh oh anderson cooper you're five foot
two 140 pounds you've got a mansion i
want that
mine now that's it me and my gang take
it
like this was humanity let me give you a
different story here let me
let's change it up a little bit so
here's here's what just happened which
is by the way absolutely crazy here
so you know most people don't understand
nfts right nfts what is an nft
non-fungible token what the hell is that
people still don't know what an nft is
you can't blame them yeah you can't
blame it
there's a lot of people that still don't
even know what a cryptocurrency
blockchain they're still trying to learn
what this is going on
this is on a whole different level kai
did you find a story or not that i
emailed you
check this out guys this is this is
seriously insane to me
okay when i show this to you i hope your
reaction is as crazy as my reaction is
when i saw this story
italian artist sells an invisible
structure for more than
a sculpture for more than eighteen
thousand dollars
you have to see the picture by the way
go up see if the picture is there where
he's standing there
that's the sculpture
i'm not kidding with you the italian
sculpture sold an invisible sculpture
for eighteen thousand two hundred
dollars
this is this is the era we're living in
can you imagine guy says
it's yours take it you
take it watch your step watch your step
my sculpture's here
hey you know what hey here's the problem
half the left would be offended by it
oh my god italian italian artist gets
away with money laundering
that's the actual sculpture that's sold
for look at that beautiful discovery
press press play
just right there just lower your audio
guy look at that beautiful
18 grand right there imagination run
wild unbelievable
unbelievable now buddha in contemplation
milano sculpture whatever so sells for
18 000
in the middle what am i doing wrong this
is what am i this is part of this
everybody's thinking what do i have that
i could possibly sell you know
the uh well make it up charlie bit my
finger those guys made
you know they're doing an ft on the
video
you know everything every everywhere
there's people work 12 hours a day in
this office
they're going to see this and they're
just going to break down in tears you
remember the movie drop that fred
do you remember when you guys had an
imaginary friend that's like 30 40 years
ago
it's actually a really good movie it's a
funny movie so folks today who
imagine like my son is one that says you
know he imagines he has a certain friend
or he has
certain things today you can imagine say
i own the largest castle in the world
and i'm willing to sell it to you for a
million dollars
it's and it's right there take a break
it's right there that's right beautiful
you know one time my uncle my uncle my
uncle had a very very uh
unique sense of humor like a yogi berry
sense of humor so but he couldn't stand
arrogant rich people my uncle my dad's
brother
so one day they're hanging out with a
few friends i've told the store a few
times
they're hanging out with a few friends
and everybody's bragging one guy says
yeah i own a bunch of pecan dealerships
pecan and iran is like toyota dealership
it's a french car but pecan dealers oh
wow that's great
how about yourself yeah i own multiple
hotels you know oh great
how about yourself i want a waterfront
property how about yourself i have this
so finally it comes to my uncle now my
uncle owns nothing the only thing he
owns is a deck of cards that's
it he knew how to play poker and that's
he was a hustler right
and he drove slow he walked slow
everything about him
was slow everything was slow but the
funniest guy in our family
so he's sitting there my dad sitting
there like oh my gosh we own nothing
what the hell are we going to say so
my uncle victor says you know
we have we have a lot of land and he
says really he says we have a lot of
land
he says where's your land at he says in
the center of caspian sea
we own a thousand acres of land clever
guys
really says yeah our family david family
we own a thousand acres of land in the
middle of caspian seasons what are your
plans with it
when it dries up we're going to build a
hotel on top of it
and by the way it's not laughing so
they're walking away saying how the hell
do you
own a thousand acres of life jasmine
my uncle today would have been a
billionaire convincing people he owns a
thousand acres
it would be way easier way easier
well with climate change being the way
it is we think it'll be seven or eight
months before the caspian sea dries up
so shout out to the person that sold
that you know sculpture man
that is money laundering right i mean
that that's just what it is i mean it
has to be look i thought i was a good
salesperson but officially i just met
the greatest salesperson hey that's the
free market though
he needs to write a book he needs to
write a book write a book on selling i
will buy it i promise you'll be the
first person to buy that book
i hate when they give the socialist ammo
so let's talk about uh netflix
netflix apparently wants to break into
the video games business
experts say that's a bad idea if you
want to go to page three tom
okay uh okay here we go netflix
apparently wants to break into the video
games business experts it's a bad idea
this is a business insider story with
over 200 million paid subscribers
worldwide netflix is an absolute
behemoth
so what's next for netflix the answer to
the question at least
in part appears to be video games
netflix is fishing around for a gaming
executive
to help it expand out its gaming
initiative while we still don't
know how much about netflix's plans one
thing is clear right now netflix getting
involved in gaming is almost certain to
fail
i do think they will try and do think
they will fail
wedbush managing director told insider
of a michael patcher told insider it's
hard to make games
indeed the video game industry is a very
risky business and even
entrenched studios with top tier talent
and years of experience regularly go
under
we have the failures of thq midway
acclaim 3do
bam adios atari info games
inner plane and probably a few others to
illustrate how hard it is
patrick said i don't see how netflix
could possibly think it can develop and
sell
games thoughts i don't like it i don't
know why they have to do it i'm a big
fan of staying in your lane i mean you
have to evolve
at times but man you got 200 million
subscribers how about focusing on a
little bit better content because i love
netflix it's great but
you know they could they could acquire
some even better content here along the
way
you know there are there's a lot of case
studies of companies that have failed at
this you mentioned them but even google
amazon and facebook
have spent hundreds of millions of
dollars trying to come up with gaming
and it doesn't work i mean coca-cola
right it's a very
good company they don't dabble in
persian rugs right
you know four seasons doesn't sell lawn
mowers i mean stay out of the gaming
industry and work even harder on the
content now i'm saying this
as a non-gamer so it's all tempered in
that
see i actually i think it's ambitious
and i think that they have the money to
play with and i think it's a good idea
frankly
i think that they have a lot of problems
you're a gamer yeah i like gaming yeah
but i i think are you a regular gamer
are you like every week you're going to
play
i was before i was a valuetainer now i
work 80 hours a week so
good and you're losing weight when
you're healthy
his tinder profile is going to change i
bench 515 pounds
which one the the the republican one of
the non-binary one
path do you realize how many came in you
would have begged
me i wish i could show you off off uh by
here i wish i could show the people i
got
i matched with a girl on hinge here in
fort lauderdale and she dumped me
in 120 seconds i lasted what i lasted
less than two minutes with this girl
well that's how she's seeing your
standards
you were gonna say something about
another two minutes
if you're an investor in netflix how are
you not pissed off by this because
there's a 95
chance they're gonna fail i need to know
more information gaming
people think that it's it's gonna be
this massive open world game
grand theft auto if they're gonna try to
compete on that level it's a bad idea
but if
if they're gaming if they're going to
gamifica uh gamificate
their their shows it's a good idea like
what they did with
bandersnatch in uh in in um black mirror
if they're going to to get into
interactive movies that they have
already with cut scenes
and it's gonna go back to like the old
school remember when we were kids and
there were books
if you think he did this turn the page
79 if they're going to have
the game if they're going to gamify
their shows it's a really really good
idea that's innovative yeah but disney
failed at that as well they tried to
game up gamify their ip and it didn't
work
that's that's disney though they also
tried to wokify everything and everybody
left so let me ask this question kai
i'm asking this from you uh david are
you a gamer or no are you
do do you game yeah yeah you're a gamer
kai are you a gamer
would you consider yourself a gamer
somewhat uh not really casually maybe
casual do you play every week or no
uh no do you play i agree with kai we
get more casually okay
so what do you think about netflix and
gaming i'm curious let's ask a different
generation what do you guys think about
gaming
what netflix going into gaming i mean it
makes sense
if you can i mean now games are moving
more into like a streaming where you can
stream things yeah
and so if netflix is popular for
streaming it makes sense but i agree
with tom in a sense just doubling down
on what you're
known for doing great at some of their
eyepieces are made for games like that
movie bright would have been a better
game than a movie
they have that it's called light bright
uh so i think i think it depends
because going into gaming is very vague
it's not necessarily that they're making
video games they could be trying to
compete with steam which is a platform
where you
buy games same way as they do for
netflix where you have subscription
models so you pay a subscription
and you have access to a wide range of
games as long as you
keep paying for the subscription um so
i'd i'd have to
want to know more specifically what are
they aiming for as opposed to just
throwing out or to kai's point let's say
that they were trying to integrate
steam with stitch where you buy the game
on their platform but then you could
also stream it to all the other people
as well
so it could they have they have a
marketplace they have a massive massive
marketplace then they have
infrastructure in place to be able to
connect
these people to one another i i don't
think it's the horrible idea that
boomers think it is i really don't
you know what they're they're they've
got their work cut out for them in the
streaming wars
i mean now that discovery has has paired
up with warner
um and there's some cup and they're
chasing uh disney right now
they're going to be chasing amazon soon
they have to do something that's going
to differentiate
they haven't been profitable ever let me
ask you questions so what are they going
to do let's just say they don't do
anything what are they going to do
they're going to keep doing this and
they're going to keep doubling that
who else has done it with that model i
mean i understand staying specialized
for a decade or two i fully get that i
think there's strength and staying
specialized for a while but
who has state specialized for 100 years
who has they specialized for 50 years
who has did amazon stay specialized for
15. for 20 years no
did walmart stay specialized walmart
stay specialized for about 50 years but
look what walmart's been doing right so
they're looking at everybody google is
probably the one that's
the most specialized they tried a couple
different things google plus didn't work
out for them
go facebook fairly specialized but they
bought whatsapp they bought instagram
they bought
a few different things if you go and
look at the model where they're at
and you're talking streaming where i can
play the game on netflix with 200
million
users and i can go in in a way where my
risk
is not that high i don't know i think
for netflix the next move could be like
remember you used to go to blockbuster
and used to go to blockbuster to buy
what
movies yep but what did they do they
came up with they were games
and it actually worked did work for
blockbuster blockbuster didn't have
their late fee
debacle going back and forth blockbuster
could still be around today
and you know if they would have i
couldn't afford to buy video games when
i was a kid but i could afford
to rent the game for five bucks five
bucks yeah so the games
so i think i think there is a business
model for what netflix wants
i'll tell you what else i'll tell you
what else too man the the concept of
um microsoft if i remember correctly we
have to go back and check but i remember
when microsoft said that they were going
to get in the gaming they caught the
same pushback
they said you guys are business software
what do you know about gaming
you're going to get destroyed nintendo
has been doing this for 20 years sony
you know and and
now without xbox where would microsoft
be like xbox is is
probably more than half their company
that's right yeah but that's a that's a
piece of equipment too right this isn't
just what what netflix is talking about
doing is virtual and streaming
they were a software company and they
became a hardware that does is that that
even decreases the
risk anything that's more physical you
got more
work manufacturing a warehouse all of
that stuff you need to do if it's going
to be virtual it's a lot easier to take
that risk i don't know
if you're watching this if you're
watching this if you think netflix id is
a good idea
smash thumbs up like meaning them going
into gaming if you're saying
absolute terrible idea i'm a netflixer
and i would never want to have video
games i play my video games on twitch
and i go watch my videos on netflix let
us know put thumbs down so good idea
thumbs up
bad eye the person we should talk to is
curt schilling curt schilling blew his
entire major league salary
on trying to start a game remember that
and he got he got the big loan from the
state
oh yeah he did he he made 50 million
disappear more than uh
if we had a podcast back in the day when
that happened and because they bailed
them out
yeah or they gave them this huge they
gave them like his whole fortune was
gone
yeah they uh does he still have money
today he has his pension
so he gets like what is that the big
league punch is what ten times
oh yeah multiple times or one he won the
but multiple times he's one of the best
pitchers in there he was a big game
pitcher
yeah yeah very interesting well we'll
see what's gonna happen now by the way
just a question for you guys here's a
question
trevor if you're listening go into
gaming
got a question for some of you guys here
if you're watching this and you're
subscribed
to this podcast not valuetainment this
podcast
if you are a subscriber if you're not
click on the subscribe button but if you
are and if you've also clicked on the
notification
i'm curious people are telling me some
channels get notified
some don't i want to know if you got
notified today when we went
live if you did just say thumbs up i got
notified if you didn't put thumbs down
no i didn't get notified i just kind of
want to see i'm looking at the charts
right now where we are
right now we got four 10 thumbs up so
i'm curious to know 10 thumbs down
based on that i'm curious enough you are
getting the notification when we are
going live
with our podcast thanks guys okay i just
got another comment here that came out
it says pbd thank you for inspiring
young entrepreneurs
i know you grew up in glendale but
there's a kid from uh nella inside of
you northeast l.a pbd knows what's up
much love brother robert rodriguez gave
25 bucks let's give robert rodriguez 250
bucks for
starting off as thursday morning with us
at 7 20 morning in
l.a i used to play uh i used to play
baseball in uh basketball in northeast
l.a
but uh there you have it okay all right
let's continue let's continue next story
let's see what you've got fouchy should
we go to fauci or now let's do the
buffett story let's do the buffett story
we're going to finish with fouchy we
gotta get some vouchers warren buffett's
favorite market indicator hits 200
signaling stocks are overpriced and a
crash may be
coming business insider story the buffet
indicator takes the combined market
capitalization
of all publicly traded u.s stocks and
divides it by the most recent quarterly
figure
for gross domestic product investor used
it as a rough gauge of the stock
market's valuation relative to the size
of the economy the wilshire 5000 total
market index climbed as high as
44.3 trillion on tuesday while the
latest estimate
for the first quarter gdp is 22.1
trillion
putting the buffett indicator at 200
percent that reading is well above the
187 it reached
in the second quarter of 2020 when the
pandemic was in full swing and gdp was
12 lower the billionaire investor
berkshire hathaway ceo added that the
indicator hit a record high
during the dot-com bubble that should
have been a very strong
warning signal of the crash to come the
yardstick also spiked in the lead up to
the global financial crisis
making it a useful tool for anticipating
market downturns this is not looking
good if he's accurate it's looking like
market crash is coming
tom what are your thoughts here's my
thoughts on this i don't care if it's
warren buffett or
jimmy buffett if he's drunk in
margaritaville right now
what about this country in the world
right now screams of stability
strength and consistency do i think a
market crash is coming
hell yes okay i don't know when i don't
know why i don't know how
but do i think it'll eventually happen
i'm gonna go with a yes
how many people that are really really
successful in the market have to come
out and say
this thing's about to crash before
people start going this thing's about to
crash
the what's the name from the big short
um uh
my the doctor no no no no what's his
name
uh he kidding me we follow this guy uh
what's his name
michael murray yeah michael berry yeah
yeah he he said this
three months ago um this is
look uh what what are we gonna do we're
gonna go to negative interest rates i
mean what how much
what what can how much longer can the fl
the fed keep blowing air in this balloon
eventually there has to be a correction
eventually we have to recognize
i mean the white house is still trying
to claim that we're one percent
inflation
with one percent inflation lumber one
number is up 150 percent
people are buying houses at over market
value because they don't think new
houses are gonna be built
this thing is coming and it's coming
hard and heavy
this thing now the big thing the big
question i asked i have because
this is something that that's above my
pay grade
how do we insulate ourselves from it i'm
i'm over
leveraged in crypto as it is i'm way
over leveraged in crypto
but how do we insulate ourselves this
thing is coming
we could see it like a slow motion train
wreck it's happening right in front of
us
how do we insulate ourselves here's a
question for you here's a question
for you what is the difference between a
market
crashing like it did in 08 in a market
tank 38 percent
right i mean it was a scary time when
the market tanked 38 the whole mortgage
you know
real estate bubble that we had or in
late 90s when the tech bubble
the whole same thing happened there's
one in silicon valley what is the
difference between a market crash
and uh major hyperinflation what's the
difference
the time the amount of time it takes to
recover so what is the difference
let me ask a question one more time so
one is the market crashes meaning the
dow goes from
whatever 30 to what is it right now 34
000 and change 33 000 and change
so the dow goes from 34 000 to 22 000
versus the dow stays 34 000 goes to 40
000.
but your money is but inflation goes up
10 what is the difference
i would guess a lot of wealthy people
are going to be less wealthy in a crash
as opposed to inflation where it affects
everybody day to day
that would be my microeconomic
explanation ebbs and flows markets can
crash and then they can rise inflation
never goes back down
so the value will never come back that's
the point so the point is
in a situation like this either
buffett's gonna be right
we're going to have a major market crash
or
we're going to have hyperinflation one
of the two is going to happen if it's
just good options just so you know if
the market crashes
look everybody loses money okay but if
there's hyperinflation
guess what happens the rich get richer
and the gap gets white
why because the rich own they have more
equity and the poor
don't yeah the poor are day-to-day cash
and spending so
if it does happen that it is
hyperinflation
this means if you don't own assets that
are not duplicatable
you're going to lose a lot pensioners
really really should be afraid
people with pensions if you own assets
that are not duplicatable you're about
to make a lot of money so
but either way it's very important to
understand the difference between the
two market crashes one thing
inflation is another thing inflation may
happen and some wealthy people may be
sitting there saying listen i
should i don't care my you know 10
million uh you know my 100 million
dollar real estate portfolio is 150
million dollars
yeah people can't afford it i get it
it's expensive i get it but guess what
i'll take loans but a person who doesn't
own any assets they're sitting there
saying
i can't afford to pay ten dollars for
this gas i can't afford to pay six
dollars for this milk
so that's what we're gonna one of those
two is gonna happen and i'm and i'm
thinking the inflation is gonna hit
the poor and middle america way harder
than it always does could there be
something a little bit more in the
middle like a correction or is he going
all-out crash i mean there is a little
bit of a difference there too
we're going to have both happening at
the same time we're all we are already
in the beginning stages of inflation
whether it gets to hyperinflation i hope
that there's really really smart people
i don't think both
is going happen do you mean to tell me
you think the market's gonna like
where's it gonna crash
tell me where dallas can you pull up
down right now how can they keep rates
this low
no i know that but but can you pull up
dow right now pull up down right now
okay um that was 34 000. go to five year
yeah go to the five year that was good
so five years what
uh uh i mean they just go to max forget
it go to max okay if you go to max from
1986.
okay there's uh 1981 993
1986 keep going slowly do exactly what
you're doing go slowly
okay why don't we hit 2000 go to okay
2000 is what
87 okay when do we hit 3 000
go go go go go go go go go let me ask
you this
watch this though but i want to show you
something here keep going three thousand
keep going
go to the next market a high before it
drops go to like whatever looks like two
thousand keep going
boom we hit 11 000 right there wherever
it was i just saw eleven thousand okay
eleven thousand one ninety two
give me the low give me the low right
after that what's the low
okay we dropped 30 percent let's just
say now go to the high in 2007
with 14 000 what's the drop 6 500 go to
the low
uh 6 500 remember that yeah 2008 yeah
now go keep going up keep going up keep
going up keep this entire time
gerrard just so you know we're printing
money this entire time i don't know if
you know that or we keep printing money
we keep printing money we keep printing
money we keep bringing the money
keep going keep going keep going keep
going 128 months of economic expansion
boom then covet happens it drops to what
18 i think it's 18
if you get it right we've had six
trillion since february of 2020
you're right six trillion what i'm
trying to say to you is
i don't think the market's going to
crash
i think inflation and interest rates are
going to hit the market when it does
to me it is a form of a market crash but
those who don't own
assets that are not duplicatable are
about to get destroyed yeah
gotta have it well you know the whole
thing about rich get rich or poor get
poor rich kid
guy asked me a question one time chris
he still he got animated he was upset
you rich people he's still over you rich
people this was in
09 2000 you rich people you have all
your money probably in offshore accounts
i'm like dude i don't have
i don't have any options are they
talking about those so you you rich
people do this i said what what you rich
people
here's what rich people do look at the
gap you cannot tell me this is not a
republican or democratic thing
it is a thing that's happening everybody
agrees that rich keeps getting rich and
poor gets
keeps getting poor yes because there's
this thing called
compound interest if i'm making 12 a
year
or 10 percent a year and you keep
wasting your money making a half a
percent on a saving account
you're right you are never going to come
losing again you're losing
every single year so you ought to study
how to so
e let's just say inflation happens so
now becomes the hedge how do i hedge
against the market crash
how do i head against the market crash
gold what other way
property what other one ethereum
ethereum
okay how do i hedge against the market
crash how do i hedge against a market
crash
depending on my age depending on my age
on where you are maybe go look at the
way your money's
managed how much equities do you have
how much bonds do you have how much fix
do you have
where's your money at based on your age
so you may want to have your portfolio
i'm a little i'm a little afraid
because my parents have been saving for
retirement saving savings savings
they've been austere for years for
retirement and they're going to save a
certain amount of money that they think
is going to be
good enough for them to live out the
remainder of their life and if inflation
hits
that money is going to be halved so and
they and they're not going to have the
wherewithal
and i don't want them to have the
wherewithal an ability to go out and be
an earner
into their 70s that's not that i don't
want that for my parents
but if they think that they're gonna
save five million dollars and that's
going to hold them for the next 20 years
and that turns out to be two essentially
two and a half million dollars in in
equity
that that's going to be that that's
that's a pretty devastating thing you
know what we're learning today with the
conditions that we have it is so
weird what we've done with print this
printing money thing is a new thing this
printing money is not like a
they robbed us yeah they gave it they
gave it to themselves yes you're right
they did and by the way even stephen
stanley druckenmiller who's a 10 billion
you know guy worth 10 billion we showed
on the last podcast he says
you have no idea how much money i've
made during this time he said they keep
printing money thinking the money flows
through the pour into middle america
all the money flows all the way to the
top it was the raytheon all i'm saying
to you is
the the form of a market crash i think
if it happens it's subtle it's not as
big as people think maybe a 20 to 30
percent
you know there may be something like
that but that's going to be a time
that's not going to last a long time
the inflation if this happens
if milk goes eight dollars yeah
if you're buying if gas goes to i
produced
a gasoline ten dollars i predict it's
going to go five to ten
gas is nuts but that's that's but ten
dollar gas is nothing to a person who
has money
so i'm trying to tell you ten dollar
guess so so it's not a market crash
it's those who are not making the right
decisions financially today if
somebody's listening to this and they're
saying well pat how do i
how do i fight against this here's what
i will say whatever you're doing
the next couple years make money and
figure out a way
to buy some assets that are not
duplicatable give me an example of
non-duplicate can
can a person duplicate land okay
can a person duplicate gold can a person
duplicate bitcoin
can a person duplicate a michael jordan
rookie card
can a person duplicate a mickey mouse
you know the wayne gretzky card i sold
you know the wayne gretzky did you hear
about what happened with the wayne
rooney sold again
that's not your card it was the other
guys
i sold it for 1.29 million dollars okay
six months ago there was two of those
cards i had the psa 10. the other guy
had the psa 10.
mine was a little lesser quality than
the other psa 10.
the people who knew like there's three
mickey mantle cards right now that are
psa 10 right
52 tops the the lowest quality psa 10
because they
gauge it based on when it was graded so
depending on when your card got graded
it's a more legitimate psa 10
so that's how they gauge it so if you
guys gauge a certain area well they're
giving away psa tens
if you got gauge in a later era they're
not giving away psa 10.
so the the three numbers i'm starting
buying packs of cards like lottery
tickets between
15 million to 30 million dollars the
difference between the three mickey
mouse
right between 15 million to 30 million
dollars the lowest psa 10
the highest psa 10. my my wayne gretzky
card i sold six months ago for 1.29
million it was a record now
most expensive hockey card ever sold the
record got broken last week the card
sold for 3.5 million dollars
same exact card except owned by the
other guy three and a half million
dollars
because you cannot duplicate a gretchen
source some socialist is listening this
in a brooklyn cafe and their blood is
boiling yeah right now all i'm saying is
all i'm saying to you right now
is you have to take your finances very
seriously
the market crash fine inflation
scary incredibly scary if inflation
inflation takes place well look at this
is reflecting jimmy carter's
administration
and inflation was never higher than then
and the exact same thing is probably
going to happen
i mean he's following the playbook of
one of the least successful presidents
we've ever had well done
and we're so so we're going to we're
going to engage in proxy wars after this
you know what i want to do i want to
call this lady i want to call lose if
you're on i'm about to call you lose
acosta pondolfi
who works with the santis okay she's
saying desantis is making some head
waves
i'm gonna call this uh uh lucier lose
let's see if you're gonna pick up
if you're listening we are about to call
you live she works with
desantis and she's saying that he he is
making some positive
influence let's see she works for the
government of uh
the state of florida can you hear her or
no i did
in my headset can you hear or no okay
good here we go
hello luce how are you oh how are you
i'm very good i'm very good so lewis you
are based out of florida
yes i am tallahassee florida okay very
cool i know what that is when uh
department of insurance is also out of
tallahassee i've been to tallahassee a
few times
seminoles yes yes all of our state all
of our state agencies are
housed here in tallahassee i work for
the florida department of revenue
so you work for the florida department
of revenue tell us what you think
governor desantis is doing and i think a
big part of this was after gerard made a
comment saying he feels
a desantis tulsi gabbard or desantis
mansion you know a mansion a ticket
could be a good one and then i saw your
comment come two minutes after he made
that comment so what are your thoughts
about desantis what can we know about
him
well the simple fact is he's making
common sense judgments
and for as much as you want to hate
republicans and i'm not a republican i'm
an independent
okay but i work with a lot of
democrats and they're following oh you
know
the republicans are out to get us they
hate us and this and that and it's like
and right with with trump they were just
oh the santa is just following trump's
quote pills and i'm like
no you have to look at policy stop
looking at
favoritism amen and look at what is
being done
so let me ask you do you like do you
like desantis more than you like trump
i could i can honestly tell you i like
both
okay um i didn't vote for trump in 2016.
interesting because i'm from new york i
lived in new york okay
we went to school there yeah and i knew
how trump was and i was thinking okay
trump is going to make a mockery of
everything the man is just about for
himself and making a dollar yeah
he will sell us to the highest bidder if
he's president interesting i could hear
that section
sent the whole yeah i knew it i knew it
from the first first word she said
he's already flirting don't let your arm
get you stay focused you lose we want to
get value from you tell us
tell us what policies of the sanchez is
influencing the other side i'm trying to
get in with the government
the last the last few especially the one
that he most recently signed recently
concerning the girls
and same-sex yeah playing in sports
that has come that has been a milestone
in leaps and bounds in these last couple
of days in what way
because a lot of people even though they
are
liberal they did agree that that is not
fair
because boys even if they change to be a
girl they're still biologically a boy
they're going to be stronger and faster
than a girl
biologically do you know what she's
talking about
yeah of course
technically i could without
transitioning i could technically say
that i was a woman and still have one
year of eligibility left and go play
softball against
17 year old girls tomorrow you break
every record with a metal bat mind you
so i mean it's insanity are you thinking
about it if it was money involved they'd
do it tomorrow
200-foot fences too yeah
yeah so that was one of the most recent
things that has a lot of people
you know thinking twice and it was one
of the things that was happening
especially now when
for re-election i did vote for trump
because in those first four years he did
change my mind
huh interesting so you didn't in 16 you
did in
and now you're 2020 that if desantis ran
so you would much rather have desantis
run in 2024 than trump
um i would i don't mind either one
because
trump has um shown a lot and he's proven
me wrong yeah
in my original assessment of him the
only thing i can be like everyone else
his delivery on saying things that was
my main issue with him
but it wasn't that he wasn't telling the
truth he was telling the truth no just
needlessly adversarial yeah he can't
help himself yeah i would go with
desantis
totally less confrontational better
chance to align people
and you know it follows that platform or
jimmy carter turns it over to a strong
governor from a big state ronald reagan
it's interesting that um it's
interesting that you said that the
democrats
uh are are being won over is there
anything in particular that desantis is
doing that's
that's helping to kind of bridge that
gap
it's it's all the little things that
he's doing especially towards state
employees
with us because you know we we just
received a
increase what two years ago and before
that it was seven years before that
you know we have the union that comes
hard at us
oh we need to stop this we need to stop
that however i
because i am considered an exempt
employee
i'm not covered by the state's ask me
union i am technically what is
considered i work at the
leisure of the governor if my if
budgeting cuts has so happened to happen
guess what being that i'm a select
exempt employee
minds could be one of the first
positions to go hey i'm not essential
too
yeah awesome louise thank you so much
for this uh appreciate you
uh stay on with us uh we we appreciate
you listening to the podcast thank you
love you guys keep doing a great job
thank you bye bye bye bye
she said common sense that's what's up
influence is taking place she's working
for
the state that's pretty weird to be
working for the state you're not making
a lot of money but you're seeing the
different impact taking place very very
interesting
yeah i uh that was great to hear okay
all right sounds good by the way
somebody said here pat when you go live
i do get your notifications and i do see
your uh
uh podcast when it goes live guys if you
are that's great i
suggest if you're listening to this and
you want to be notified the moment we're
going live click also the notification
button
after you subscribe so you're notified
every time we go live on the podcast
okay
next topic uh amazon backs marijuana
legalization
drops we testing for some jobs so amazon
amazon backs marijuana legalization
drops we testing for some jobs it's a
fox business story amazon said on
tuesday it supports a proposed
u.s legislation to legalize cannabis at
the federal level and would stop
would drop we testing requirements for
some uh recruitments
amazon will also no longer screen as job
applicants for marijuana use for any
position not regulated by the department
of transportation
amazon's consumer boss dave clark said
while many u.s states have legalized
marijuana u.s employers
have so far largely refused to work with
the industry as cannabis is still
classified substance at the federal
level amazon was hit with a proposed
class action lawsuit
which claimed that the company was
violating a new york city law by testing
applicants for jobs
at local facilities for marijuana the
company does not allow marijuana
sales on its platform i think yet but i
think it will very soon time
you know this clearly speaks of one
thing bezos and lauren sanchez are
throwing some ragers
and he's getting high and it's a bad
look for the company if he's not
pro-marijuana
you know they have north of a million
employees you think they're going to be
able to continue to grow
if they're going to ban everybody that
smoke pot give me a break i mean that's
going to slow down their growth so they
had to do that
and plus we all know they're gearing up
for the pharmaceutical they're gonna i
think
what they do in pharmaceuticals is gonna
dwarf what they do with amazon prime
video i mean this is just right for them
to destroy
clearly there's a market in cbd they're
gonna be doing that
um and they're all in on getting it
legalized federally and if
amazon is behind it it's getting done
they didn't want a union in alabama it
didn't happen what they want they get
done over they're going to be selling it
within a year i think
selling it within a year some version of
it something we're going to see some
real legitimacy we'll see
there's cbd already on amazon absolutely
i think
look again um what pisses me off and i
gotta be honest it really does tick me
off
is we are going to be able to buy weed
that's delivered to you via a drone
before we let people out of prison who
are in jail for selling
a leaf and that bothers me to no end it
bothers me to no end
that kamala harris in particular uh
has put i think pat you told me it was
people in jail for for minor marijuana
offenses and she has the balls to own
stock in marijuana companies
can you imagine the balls on this woman
to put people in jail for weed and then
be a part owner in a weed company so
look i think
look this is a free market thing i love
it i think you should be able to buy
weed i think you should be able to buy
mushrooms i think you should be able to
buy lsd
whatever you want whatever consenting
adult wants to do in their free time
they should be allowed to do it and you
know what if martin if i can have a
drone deliver it to me
even better even better man deliver me
my cheetos my weed
straight into my room i don't need to
leave i'm a happy camper okay
but i don't i cannot live in a society
where where my fat ass can be sitting on
a couch eating cheetos and smoking a
bowl while somebody is in jail for 30
years
for trying to provide me with that
happiness it's nonsensical that we are
still doing this
put get let these people out of jail
tomorrow let them out of jail today
if amazon is able to sell weed and you
have people in jail for selling weed
we have a a a a morally corrupt society
i'm sorry that that's just
that to me is one of these things it's
just it it's a wrong that we have to
write
be nice if they could yeah i did that i
did this last time i was on too i left
the room with an awkward silence i'm
sorry
let me tell a joke do you know anybody
in prison for selling wheat i do okay
well or i would say i know people that
went to prison for selling weed and it
irrevocably changed their life for the
worse
we don't and that's the other thing
about not to get on volume of weed
well yeah but i mean but weed is also
other things right like i mean you get
you do weed you do this you do that like
you know whatever i mean when they were
rehabilitated
they were never anything but an ex-felon
either so it irrevocably changed their
their life for the worst and again we're
looking at it now that this is like a
fortune
a fortune 5 company is selling this
stuff you know but but
you know tom from the jersey shore goes
to jail and then you have
now even more if you want to talk about
a real guy russ albrick
russ ulbrick is going to spend the rest
of his life in jail for having the silk
road
which essentially was the dark web
amazon for drugs
and now amazon's going to sell drugs so
again we have a morally corrupt society
i'm sorry i think they're going to open
up pharmacies
inside whole foods too i i think they
and dude i think they should
look you're consenting adults and also
the whole idea of you have to drug test
your employees it says more about your
management
that they can't tell when their
employees are messed up that they have
to go drug test
i remember being in the minor leagues
man i remember being in the minor
leagues and weed was illegal
but we could take as many percocets as
we want like toradol was fine we could
get a shot in our arm that made our body
go numb
and then you'd go play and now guys
would play and they pitchers
specifically
they would turn their bodies into
chemistry sets that once every five days
they can go
out and throw 95 miles an hour tear
everything in their arm they wouldn't be
able to to wash their hair after the
game it would take them three days to
lift their arm up
pop a couple perks and get back out
there and do it again
now you do that for five or six years
and then the team decides they don't
want you anymore hey thanks for your
service bud and they cut you
and now you got to go be a gym teacher
somewhere or or
gas stations attendant and you don't get
to tell your body hey i don't need 30
perks this week
and now they're they're addicted to
painkillers and the next thing you know
that that's
this is who their life is now i'm not
saying that weed is great and people
should i don't even smoke weed to be
honest with you i'm joking i don't even
smoke weed i don't like who i am on weed
i don't need anything to help me be fat
lazy and hungry i got that covered okay
so that i'm good at came naturally this
came with the gi joe
the kung fu grip with that all right
yeah you know but the
shake what your mama gave you but i'll
tell you what i'll tell you what
when my body was hurting my body was
hurting and i was playing ball
you could give me some celebrex and a
percocet and i'd be zoomed zoom and then
a perk would make me a little loopy so
i'd take an adderall to get back on
and i never once thought i was taking
drugs i thought i was playing the game i
thought i was doing what i had to do to
win
but that's a party yeah i got a
celebration of perkins and adderall
way more addictive than marijuana by the
way yeah and you know the sad thing is
nfl players that can't monitor or
you know regulate their pain imagine you
know with marijuana which would help
them
you know what we did we drank ourselves
to sleep so all i'm saying
is is that this is an antiquated model
it's an antiquated model
a lot of it comes from robber barons who
owned
certain industries and use lobbying to
not have those industries be
be competed against both alcohol and
believe it or not timber there was a big
reason that marijuana was illegal in the
first place
is i i don't want to get this wrong but
i believe it was rockefeller owned
millions of acres of wood and hemp
actually was a better source for pulp
for paper
and he wanted hemp illegal so that they
had to use his wood for paper in all in
every school in america
instead of the hemp pulp somebody has to
look that up
you know but but yeah yeah
you know you know one time i sat down
with oscar goodman i don't know if you
know oscar good morning
from uh mayor of vegas that was a great
time mayor vegas and then his wife's now
been the two-time era vegas so for the
last 20 years
the goodmans have been running uh vegas
and he was in a movie casino he was in a
movie casino representing
you know when the whole thing was taking
place sharon stone all those guys were
at his house they were putting parties
together
and he told me he said i said so what do
you think about drugs he says anybody
wants to use it use it how about
prostitution do it it's your body how
about this
how about stealing nope if you're going
to steal from me we should cut your
thumb off
cut yourself off he says yes because
you're taking something that's mine
i think what is happening no harm what
is happening naturally
libertarian philosophies are creating so
much momentum
naturally the only challenge is freedom
wins the only challenge is
there's never been a libertarian
candidate
worth promoting that knows how to
inspire and convert
mindset it's such a simple logical
concept to sell to people they've not
had a good crusader yet and hopefully
they'll find somebody that'll be able to
do it
let's go to the story the fouchy story
our society is really
totally nuts fauci wrote in emails now
made public usa today's story emails
sent by dr anthony fauci
in the early days of the pen they make
reflect the thoughts of a patient but
weary man who was flabbergasted by his
overnight
celebrity hundreds of emails were
obtained by the washington post and
other uh organizations
through freedom of information acts
request fauci responds to hundreds of
interrogators
many he doesn't know often in in-depth
answers fauci also corresponded on
multiple occasions
with george gow a top infectious disease
official in china gao sent an
uh encouraging note when fauci was being
blasted by trump supporters who blamed
him for supporting social distancing
rules that closed
schools tanked the economy and
threatened trump's re-election prospects
thank you for your kind note voucher
replied three days later
all is well despite some crazy people in
this world fauci marveled
at an april 2020 story titled cuomo
crush
and fauci fever sexual sexualization of
these men as
a real thing on the internet fauci
forwarded the email to someone whose
identity
was redacted urging the person to click
on the link it would blow your mind
fauci wrote our society is really
totally nuts it continues not the story
by business insider
a leading scientist said the world needs
to understand the origins of kobit 19 to
prevent kobe 19.
uh okay this goes into a different email
i'll stop right here go with the email
so tell me fouchy emails what are your
thoughts gerard you can go first
try to hold it together by the way man
bro
first of all whoever wrote that glowing
review i was watching cnn last night
because i hate myself
and i they they were like
this man those emails showcased the the
one
the one honest man in a dishonest
organization i was like you
i i'm i i'm gonna say stuff that's gonna
get you kicked off youtube bro
i gotta calm it down for just a second
dude i got kicked off of facebook
i got kicked off i got demonetized 120
000 plus
followers i built this thing over years
national tours
i had all my videos i was selling my
tours and facebook i woke up one day and
they just said that's it
you have restricted access uh restricted
reach
my videos used to like i used to put out
a video and then how to no matter how
bad the video was i can count on 100
views fine whatever now put out a video
if i get 10 000 views it's a good video
right like i had 15 videos get over a
million views now if i get a video gets
over 10 000 it's a big big thing
facebook just turned me off they turned
the spigot off and the money i made
went away and you know what i did for
them to do that i
shared an article from the xcdc
director who said that it's very likely
that this disease
came from the wuhan lab now i had been
skeptical in fairness i had been
skeptical of everything i had been told
from the beginning i was very very very
cautious when this first happened
but then after two months it really took
me two months to be like man there's
something real weird about this
was everything that they described that
there's you know anybody who if you
don't wear a mask if you're if you're in
a closed air circuited area if you're
not wearing gloves
you know this your extreme danger my
first thought was
growing up in new york man i'm like yo
the homeless are dead there's going to
be homeless piling up in the streets
this is going to be a nightmare my god
these people sleep on the subways on top
of each other
they live in squalor they eat food out
of the garbage these people are going to
be dead
and then when they weren't and everybody
was was inside and it was like
you know the homeless came out like deer
in the middle of the night and i'm like
these people are fine some where
something's not being told and then they
started with this mask
and the mask stuff as if this was like a
hazmat suit
and now i've worked construction anybody
who's ever dry walled anybody who's ever
sanded
in one of those masks knows when they
take that mask off and their mouth is
completely full of particles
that that's bs anybody who's ever farted
through underwear and jeans and still
smelt it
knows it's bs the the fabric isn't doing
nothing if you're smelling that methane
then a virus can get through that mask
they placebo'd us
and you're looking at this emails and
they're trying to cover this stuff up as
if oh well you know he
he told the match because we didn't have
enough mass no that's not the story
interesting about this gerard here's
what's interesting about the story
uh it's interesting because just a week
and a half ago he said it could be
man-made then the emails were released
so why did he say a week and a half ago
it could be man-made then the emails
were wrong freedom of information
did he did he say it could be man-made
before the emails being released because
he
wanted to make sure he said that before
he was released did you see what the
very first email he sent was which one
this was in january 31st okay this this
man
doesn't just need jail he needs to be
expatriated
we need to slingshot this dude over to
beijing they can have this much comment
the first thing that he did was he found
out
that it would that this virus the one
percent of it is going to show that it
was man-made and the first thing he did
is call his assistant and call his major
donor and make sure that we are not
doing gain of function research in wuhan
anymore right
that was the first thing that he did and
then he goes
for months and months and months acting
like he doesn't know what this virus is
and where it came from
when it was the nih his place that
that that paid for the research at the
lab for this gain of function
the very first question he asked was is
it gain of function then he goes before
the
senate and rand paul specifically asked
him rand paul who's a doctor
mind you he's a doctor not a lawyer a
doctor he asked him he's like
are you doing gain of function no i'm
not doing gain of function is this guy
who you're in contact to doing gain of
function and fouchy does that that that
that smirk that
if he does gain a function he's doing it
within the rule dude
he knew from the get he knew from the
jump
exactly what this was and exactly what
it meant
and he lied to us from the beginning
this man needs to be
this man needs to be expatriated this
guy stole two years of our lives
two years of our lives he stole it and i
thought i didn't like fauci
no um you know what candace owens says
that he should go to prison i mean
that's a pretty strong statement you
know here's my thing anybody that is out
there and it is intuitive you saw what i
saw
and here's the first thing i saw about
fousey he's a weasel
okay that's the first thing i thought
the flip-flopping he's he's weak
he's affected and it just comes across
in all his press conferences
he's the highest-paid employee like
we've talked about there needs to be a
federal investigation into this this is
serious
i mean if china got away with this and
he's and he's having emails with them
saying we're going to get through this
together
i mean he's literally saying this like
they're our ally he just doesn't get it
and i'm saying his age is a factor he's
80 years old he's 30 years past his
prime
he needed to go a long time ago but here
and you know this is going to sound
funny and like i'm making fun of it but
he literally has one function he is the
mascot
of the coronavirus they put him in front
of it like a little dancing clown
and he's the little happy cherubic
little
this guy right here that is fauci he is
the mascot for the coronavirus
cheerleader wear your mask don't wear
your mask you know i even invented the
fountain
should i show them the fouchy dance pat
you want to see this
this is the fouchy dance
[Laughter]
that is right there moves buddy that's
so impressive you know he should be like
the uh
phoenix sun's gorilla and every
you talk about theater tom every every
jerk on twitter every single person in
brooklyn jersey that's
that was every karen that was screaming
trust the science
trust the science trust the science
there you go this is it
trust your science you blindly these
people in this freaking obedience cut
uh a cult who who who blindly trusts the
science
this is what you get this is the science
that you blindly trusted
and you bullied everybody into trusting
as well this is nonsense and he deserves
to be held accountable
and jail is not too far my whole point
is he's not cut out for this position he
should have been gone a long time
how did you survive trump i don't know
inspired everybody let me let me tell
you how
uh let me tell you how uh loyalty is
created loyalty is created during
tough times and how you treat somebody
during tough times right meaning
when everything is good it's like ah
yeah everything's good and then all of a
sudden somebody's going through some
stuff you're like hey man you know
distance yourself from that individual
right okay
where am i going with this just a year
ago
who was the next democratic presidential
leading candidate
uh in america a year ago cuomo he was
the biggest celebrity his book deal made
him five
million dollars he won an emmy every
day we heard cuomo right
what happened three four months ago all
of a sudden all of a sudden three four
months ago
stories started coming out where schumer
didn't like him
you know not they don't like him they
wanted the all the stories with me too
movement
you know you had the other women coming
out
everybody all of a sudden distance
themselves from who well it turned out
his policies ended up killing more
people than saying
well sure but i mean you're right but
there's a big difference between
a cuomo and a fouchy here's where i'm
going with this
here's what could potentially happen
with fauci
fouchy within the next six months if
any of these stories get the kind of
credibility that they get and create
momentum
watch how quickly everybody
on the left is going to turn against
this guy watch how
quickly this guy's going to be in an on
an island all by himself
here's here's what you have to think go
go go to fauci
in his bedroom it's 11 30 he's sleeping
at night you think he stays up that late
that
uh 100 i think right now he is imagine
it's 11 o'clock at night
and he's sitting in his office or he's
done watching the news by himself wife
everybody's asleep
he's by himself right what's he thinking
right now who's he talking to right now
he's feeling the chrome
who is he feeling supports him right now
who has his back right now
is he sitting there saying uh the media
has his back right now
maybe is he sitting there saying you
know uh
biden pelosi those guys have his back
right now i don't know
is he sitting there saying china has us
back nih has his back
cdc has his back who bill gates how many
emails were bill gates how many emails
with bill gates zuckerberg
what are you doing communicating with
zuckerberg bill gates who has us back
right now
who is backing him up right now look
how many things were considered a
conspiracy theory let's go through one
it was what it was
man-made that was one of them right that
was one of the things that
that was that was a conspiracy theory
but a chinese guy eating a pangolin
wasn't we were supposed to buy that
but that's one the other one was hydroxy
chlorine uh
uh quinn was what no it doesn't work
right and then so
a part of the email maybe gives a hint
that maybe it does work
right hey maybe it does have some kind
of positive effects
you know face masks don't work
they do work double masking it doesn't
work it does work okay
we have to figure that out lockdown was
necessary was it necessary do we really
need to do a lockdown
closing the schools yeah your schooling
all of this stuff that you sit there and
you look at
those things have to be investigated
simple as that they have to be
investigating answers
but i will tell you like this he will be
dropped
like this it will be remember comey
was a hero he went up there and he's
doing this he's doing that he's doing
this and then the one time right before
the election comey said what
there's very likely that hillary
clinton's emails and then he
flipped he flipped and then that hurt
hillary's election chances
i don't know if you remember this or not
it was right before the election comey
was their hero well we have to listen to
him because he is the fbi director you
know we have to listen to what he has to
say
then the moment he flipped all of a
sudden where's his credibility
who is he well he this is not fair he
shouldn't be saying these kinds of
things two weeks before the election
fauci comey similar camps
different areas of the camp and like
this
he'll be all by himself on an island my
sister within probably a couple
weeks i think it's going to go quick and
i think
if you all of a sudden start seeing
additional stories
stories that could go back to aids
stories that could go back 40 years
stories that
go back to women stories that could go
back the degree he got stories that
could go back he was never really a
valedictorian so just
nonsense stories like that could come
out you already kind of know what's
going to happen right after that go
ahead my
my family are democrats my sister in
particular is a pretty staunch democrat
right and um
this was my message to her because she's
actually to speaking
of if anything good has come out of the
last two years they're a little more
open
to getting off that left hard line
they're a little more open to taking in
some new information okay
and and as a libertarian i've been
ripping republicans for years
and i was i i marched against bush and
cheney in college i i was
anti uh war i was i still am anti blood
for
for oil and then i i said i told her i
was like bush and cheney are stumping
for biden now
that should be paused for reflection for
you okay and it was
in fairness to her it was one thing to
take away from this and it's a very good
point you just made patrick is that
they're dumping these guys because they
are liars
we are in the age of accountability like
i said before democrats if you're
listening to this
okay you are america's gas pedal
republicans are america's break
we need both the gas pedal we need both
to break we need you
just as as much as we we need desantis
but we need you to stop
giving your side a break you give these
people
a free pass all the time there is never
any accountability in your camp
please for the love of all that is holy
if you are listening to this
stop with the hero worship stop with the
cult of personality
dump these people dump them if they're
wrong they're wrong
bill maher to his credit who i disagree
with politically
he has already jumped off the fouchy
bandwagon it's been a month already
guys if they are wrong they bankrupted
your neighbor
they convinced you that everybody that
you interacted with was a threat to your
health
they convinced you to view your fellow
man as a threat
they put people they locked people in
their homes bankrupted them
killed them how many people with
addiction how many people with
with with uh anxiety suicidal thoughts
that they locked in a room
to serve their political ambitions guys
you've got to hold these people
accountable this can't be a trial
i mean here's what's going to happen the
the i i think
as we age we reason better and hope i
bank on a small percentage of people to
say hey what the hell is really going on
i'm getting a lot of people right now
that are contacting me saying look
uh i'm i'm a republican who questioned
trump i'm a democrat who questioned my
side there's a lot of weird things going
on right now i just
much rather find out exactly what's
going on i just want the truth
not everybody wants to true gerard you
have to realize there's a lot of people
that don't want to do there's a lot of
people that would much rather just live
a regular life don't tell me everything
that's going on
let me just go about my there's a very
small community of people that are
actually going to adjust
very small the percentage is not as big
as you think it's a five to ten percent
it's a small margin of people that are
going to sit there and say
you know what you're right i'm going to
go investigate a little bit more let's
see what's going to be taking place
and i think the next three six months
believe it or not i think things are
going to move very
very quickly and we will learn a lot
about what happened couple things here i
do want to respond a person here asked
the question i think i want to go a
little bit into this
uh first of all ben bost just gave 10
bucks and he said this morning has been
a rough
morning my wife's godfather passed away
in the middle of the night but listening
to this podcast always lifts us
up thank you pbd ben god
god bless you sorry for your loss you'll
get 10 times a 10 bucks send us a 10 uh
text to uh three one zero three four
zero one one three two three one zero
three four zero one one three two
we'll get that back over to your
condolences goes out to you and your
family somebody asked a question said
pat
uh what happens if the market crash are
cards
and collectibles still going to be doing
good let's talk about that
let's talk about how the the one
question that we didn't go into
too deep with was the following it was
how do you hedge against a market crash
how do you hedge against an inflation
how do you hedge against something
happen the market because right now
a lot of people are wondering he said
what happens if the market crashes do
you think the value of cars are still
going to go up good question it's a good
question so let's process it okay
so if there is only
one of this drink there's only one of
this okay
one there's only one in the world market
crashes
is it still only one of this in the
world in a market crash yes
is it if the market goes up is it still
only one in the world of this drink here
if there's only one
is is it still valuable during the
market crash or market exploding yes or
no in a bubble
it's valuable in both the only
difference is the amount of money out
there
of people who are willing to overpay for
this
but regardless it's still extremely
valuable because it's what
it's very rare right it's just you have
to understand that part
you don't have to worry because there's
rarity in it okay
as a as a person in a marketplace like
today let's just say we're doing a
podcast
how many people are we competing with
the podcast world how many i mean
there's a million podcasts
i don't even know if it's about i think
it's more than a million there's
probably millions of podcasts
probably the name for a podcast the
point i'm trying to say with a podcast
there's a lot of podcasts
out there okay so let's just say all of
a sudden
everybody goes into the podcast frenzy
and they create a ton of podcasts right
when a market is booming with podcasts
right
uh how many views are there in the world
let's pick in the u.s 330 million
if there's if there's more podcasts
today than ever before
are you gonna lose a little bit of
viewership on podcast sure maybe
but if your content is unique it's
valuable it's consistent
eventually what happens a year two years
three years
eventually people say you know what
these guys are most legit i'm gonna go
listen to this podcast
that you may not get the answer for what
a year or two so what's the moral of the
story here
is a rookie card of a michael jordan psa
10 going to be worth as much in a market
crash as it is today
value yes dollar amount no
dollar amount is going to adjust but the
need and the demand
the people wanting it it's still going
to be high
so i'm again my entire focus right now
when i buy stuff i buy one of ones
when i buy stuff i look at how many
things are out there a
ferrari la ferrari right now if you want
to buy okay
if you want to buy la ferrari right now
you're paying around 3.4 million dollars
why because it's numbered you know if i
if you buy an art incentive if you buy
senna mclaren right now
you're going to spend 1.2 million why
because it's numbered if you buy a
ducati lamborghini right now it's
expensive why because
it just came out and it's what it's
numbered anything that's numbered
gold is numbered so again
if if people are listening to this you
truly
have to take your finances extremely
seriously today
go sit down with an expert and asks what
the hell is going to happen
if the market crashes how do i hedge
against that and what the hell am i
going to do
if there's inflation how do i hedge
against that sitting on the sidelines
going the same way you've been going for
the last five 10 15 20
years it is not a winning formula today
times are changing and we have to adjust
at the same time as well do you think
nfts could have that in the digital
world is that
long term yes short term no i think nfts
are too volatile short term
long term yes because why yes because
today's 14 year olds are teaching the 45
year olds
today 16 year olds are saying i want to
go to a virtual museum i don't want to
go to a museum in
france i don't want to go to italy i
want to go to a virtual museum hey you
know what
in my mind i can live in a massive 30
000 square foot castle in real life i
can't live in a big castle but i can buy
a
virtual castle and have a virtual
girlfriend have a virtual
friendship and i can have a virtual
relationship i can play virtual in my
virtual world
you're right gerard i can be lebron
james you're right and that saddens me
you can also have a virtual statue
that'll cost you 20 grand
the point is call back so nft
is not going away yeah as much as people
don't understand it
we're going virtual and it's just going
to take place when vr comes out
watch watch what's going to happen to
dating scenes when vr comes out
which which woman in the world is going
to be able to please you as good as
somebody in a vr
which man in real life is going to
please you just think about the
imagination
this is like uh demolition man we're
turning into have you ever seen
demolition
this is our demolition so that's just
alone
no not just sylvester stallone and
there's another guy yeah demolition man
in um
you know those two movies combined
together so yeah
we're going in that direction wow so
it's your imagination is going to be it
but
focus on banking on things that are
one-offs a book let's just say for
example
you have an old-school book of uh give
me a famous book from the 40s give me a
third old school book uh fahrenheit uh
kill a mockingbird something
yeah 1984 let's just say okay so if you
want an original
first edition first print first sleeve
everything high quality
guess what that book is going to be
worth a lot of money
so if you own one of those keep it
that's going to go up in the next 10 20
years because there aren't
many of those out there so it's like a
high level arbitrage market is that
let me let me put it to you this way
this game of having one-offs
or numbered items go use your
imagination right now go think about
what's numbered
anything that's not yeah
uh thrift shops and antique stores all
across the world
numbers i'm looking at number numbered
shoes numbered
anything numbered uh uh uh uh watches
numbered anything that's numbered
anything that's limited anything that
cannot be
duplicated anything that can be
reprinted fiat currency
is not high quality now if you own
a five thousand dollar currency which
there's only a limited amount i don't
even think it's illegal for you to have
a ten thousand dollar currency the ten
thousand dollar currency if you have it
it's illegal by the way the government
confiscated all of them is that right
yeah it is i think it's the ten thousand
out of five
but if you own a five thousand dollar
currency it ain't five thousand dollars
that's a
that's a twenty thirty forty thousand
that's like the 19 the 1915
number so that's the number like you
know how they do these hey
uncirculated nickels okay of 1988
and you're gonna get 500 of them okay
yes there's some value to that that's
going to go up so anything that's
numbered pay very very close attention
to it
uh and this is not just baseball cards
this is art this is real estate this is
a lot of different things
so one of the ways to hedge against
inflation in a market crash you're very
bullish on
the collectibles market i'm bullish on
anything that cannot be duplicated
think about like you know you build a
structure you build a nice house and
let's just say it was built on o3 and an
o3 people like the spanish
style house and it's you know the yellow
color and then you know the
color that style right yeah what is the
value of that
nothing nothing it's done you got to pay
to get it redone
done yeah because someone's going to
come in they're going to rebuild again
but what didn't lose the value
the land yeah so land cannot be
duplicated structure can be duplicated
so
there are certain things that you have
to know is not going away
anything that cannot be duplicated
that's going to increase in value over
the next five ten
and not just over the next five ten
fifteen years forever
it's always going to gain you know the
rescue card that lose uh sold for
three and a half million dollars you
want me to give you a prediction that
car is going to sell for 50 million
dollars wow
5-0 oh yeah but but it could sell for 50
million
10 years from now 20 years from now 30
but it's going to why
there's only two of them at ps10 that's
what i mean by that
so anything you're doing pay attention
to that
you have to hedge today people have to
hedge today
there's a lot of craziness going on
people are worried about market crash
i'm worried about hyperinflation
and that inflation is coming that's the
one part that you can like you know how
people keep saying
i have a lot of videos on market crash
eight signs to prepare for market crash
10 signs market crash is coming all
these other things every time i market
crash
a mar a form of a market crash is
massive
massive inflation hyperinflation but
that doesn't mean dow's gonna drop
it's quiet people have to understand
there's a big difference you think the
republicans are relying on that and
knowing that this could correct itself
you know with the house in a couple of
years that if inflation does hit in a
big way
then it's automatically going to happen
well you guys do you think that could be
part of their strategy are they smart
enough to forward think and
and see that it's coming you guys are a
little older than me you lived
like i was born 80 86 so you guys
you live through carter in transitioning
into
reagan right no i don't remember it i
don't remember i was alive
yeah yeah sure well i'm just wondering
because i mean like you said we're we're
kind of
16 inflation 16 uh you you got
cds that was giving you 16 percent in
1979 1980 1991
i mean that's insane to be thinking
about that but at the same time if you
got a loan
you were paying for 18 loan you got a
million dollar loan you're paying 18
interest on a home on a home loan that's
insane so when that
so so people have to understand when
that
comes this is all you have to think
about the simple ways to break down the
math
to say now it's 40 000. so the the
market's going to be able to the
politicians are going to be able to say
what
under my administration the dow went up
30 percent you know
that kind of stuff right yeah so that's
marketable but what people are not going
gonna realize is
under the last seven years my monthly
expenses went from twenty four hundred
dollars
to forty two hundred dollars that's life
changing your dollars worth one sixth of
what it was
that's scary and that's coming there's
nothing you can do about that
that's inevitable that is coming you can
say whatever you want to say
that part 100 is coming a hundred
percent that point we adjust to it too i
mean 100 years ago a slice of pizza was
10 cents
yes so i mean we do adjust but people
people people who are not prepared
like anything else in life if you're not
prepared for it you're going to take a
message are wages going to be able to
keep up with inflation do you think
the the are wages going to be able to
keep up with inflation
yes uh yes and no because it's still
going to go down to being specialized
if you don't have a specialized skill
you're still going to take a massive hit
if you don't have a specialized skill or
you're on a contract like teachers
if you don't have a specialized skill
and there's a ton of you doing what
you're doing
yes now what jobs are taking off right
now look at the number one job right now
that kids are going to college
parents if you're having a conversation
with your kids and your kids want to
know what to do you know how parents
typically say what go be a doctor go be
a lawyer
software engineer cyber security oh yeah
they couldn't hire you fast enough
you were there security today is they
name your own price
they're all you graduate from school
with a cyber security degree they're
overpaying for it right now
like hey what do you want i want a
hundred twenty thousand dollars here you
go you'd have 50 offers
the first day it's insane right now for
cyber security it's insane right now for
predictive analytics it's insane right
now for
you know uh uh engineer it's you know
it's certain things you're going through
right now so if you have a specialized
skill you're going to be fine
but uh if you don't the next five ten
years
hurry up and go increase your value to
market that's a hedge as well
that's a hedge right now up and increase
your market value today
hurry up increase your market value
inflation is coming
guaranteed it's coming anyways okay gang
really enjoyed doing this uh podcast
here with you guys if you enjoyed it
smash that subscribe button
uh and smash the thumbs up and we will
not be doing podcasts next week but we
will be coming back
next tuesday so whatever the following
tuesday is i don't know the exact date
we'll be back i think it's uh 15. it's
the 15th we'll be back tuesday
same time on the podcast having said
that uh have a wonderful weekend
everybody enjoy all the madness and the
media the next
week or so because we're not going to be
with you take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you